cool so um I'm here with David Foster
welcome to mlsd well thanks very much
for having me on pleasure to be here
amazing well um David is very very well
known because he wrote this book
generative deep learning and I myself
read this book in about 2018 or 19 when
it first came out and there's now a
second edition and we're going to be
running a competition actually so um I
think what we're going to do we've got
three e-books to give away and the three
best comments on the YouTube Right
unfortunately we don't have podcasts
comments
um the three best high effort comments
we will send you an ebook so there you
go you've got two weeks
um anyway so in the second edition of
the book
um I'm just looking at a table of
contents so there's a chapter on
generative modeling deep learning uh
some of the methods so variational
autoencoders Gans Auto regressive models
normalizing flow models energy-based
models and diffusion models and then you
speak about some of the applications so
there's Transformers Advanced scans
music generation and World models and
multimodal models so um why don't you
just give us a little bit of a story
about the first edition of the book what
was it like to write it and what's
coming now in this second edition yeah
well thanks again for having me on
pleasure to be here
um I feel yeah this whole journey of
writing this book has been I feel like
I've completely overlapped with how
generative modeling has evolved over the
last five years from a very Niche field
back in 2018 when I first started
writing through to now probably the
hottest Topic in Tech I would say and I
think the process of writing the book
has been one that I've had to keep up
with the latest trends and Technologies
and I think what I hope comes across in
the book is that it this is a book for
beginners because we're all beginners
ultimately with a lot of these
Technologies there's no there's very few
people who can honestly say they've been
working with this field for you know 10
20 years so I hope what's coming across
in the book is that anyone can pick this
up and start becoming an expert with
base models such as various should also
encoders I think are a fantastic place
to start and gets you know get get
working with these kind of Technologies
but then quickly moving on to state of
the art like Transformers and diffusion
models
um so yeah I feel very privileged to be
in the position where I can write this
book and it's yeah it's been it's been a
fascinating Journey for me personally
but also to see this field evolve has
been been fantastic really really
exciting
fantastic so let's talk a bit about the
landscape of some of these models so I
mean going back in time a little bit
there's been a real Trend towards this
concept of self-supervised learning so
we kind of like use the data to train on
essentially we're seeing that with um
Transformers and language models we're
seeing it with vision models so sketch
out the landscape yeah um okay so
generative modeling really you know
spans I would say six main families of
model
um you've got one of the first kinds of
model that were introduced bearish in
all twin coders back in late 2013.
um you've then got things like Gan so
this is where we're treating the problem
as a almost as a competition between the
generator and the discriminator
um we're looking for the generator to
get stronger as a result of the
discriminator also getting stronger and
being able to detect what is fake and
what is real
um you've then got some fairly sort of
Niche kinds of model that I think are
also very important to learn about so
normalizing flows being one of them and
this is where we look to enact a change
of variables on the domain in order that
we can simplify the problem and we
constrain the way in which the model is
set up and so that we can reverse the
process so we can move from image to
noise but also from noise to image
energies based models are another kind
of family I would say they are the
predecessor of some of the
state-of-the-art image text to image
models such as diffusion models
um and again they they look to almost
treat the um the process of generating
an image as a landscape through which
you're moving and you have to find the
way to move along this landscape in a
way that moves towards realistic images
and away from those that aren't as
realistically generated
um and then of course yes there's
Transformers but that's part of a wider
set of models called Auto regressive
models
um so many of you listeners I'm sure
will have heard of things like lstms and
gius they're early forms of Auto
regressive models where you're always
trying to predict a few one usually one
time Step Ahead um so whether that's one
word or one token Transformers do the
same thing but they just do it using a
different mechanism called attention
um so they're not recurrent in nature
means they're easily paralyzable and
they are now obviously state of the art
for things like you know GPT
um as a decoder style Transformer but
then there's other model types like T5
which is encoder decoder and then you've
got other kinds of Transformers as well
like Bert which aren't necessarily
generative but are still very important
for
um for natural language understanding uh
the final type of model is the diffusion
model and so this is where in companies
like stability AI have really made
progress with their stable diffusion
model and I would say most of the state
of the Arts texture image models these
days are based around diffusion
um but that's not to say that you know
we need to just throw all of the other
kinds of model like Gans out of the
window
because actually a lot of the ideas from
Gans such as having a discriminator to
be able to tell fake from real images
are still very much used in models like
vqan
um and the earlier UK vqvae so we need
to remember when we're when we're
studying generative modeling not just to
go after the latest fad and the latest
model type because just around the
corner there may be a completely new
idea that borrows Concepts from
normalizing flows or borrows Concepts
from energy energy-based models you know
a few years ago Gans were all the rage
so when anybody could talk about was
Gans you know it was a new Gan every
week and suddenly out of nowhere comes
to Fusion models in 2020
um there's a whole new idea and suddenly
those who understood energy-based models
were at the Forefront of the field
because they could they could talk about
this and build models that were just so
much more powerful in so many ways
um and so I think what I've tried to do
with this book is lay out the landscape
and say look this is where we are today
uh who knows where we're going to be in
another five years time whether it will
still be Transformers we're talking
about or whether it's going to be
something else whether it's going to be
diffusion models or we're going to swing
back to cans in some way I think what's
important is that we keep a broad mind
when we're studying a field like this
because what's certain is that it will
move fast and those who understand it
from scratch will be the ones in the
best place to take advantage of it
so um there's something really
interesting about recurrence in in
general so you spoke about these Auto
regressive models like rnns lstms
Transformers and so on and um recurrence
is actually something which is in
diffusion models and even in cellular
automata so there's something very
interesting about
um over a fixed number of time steps
iterating and iterating and
um it's the same thing in in cellular
automata or diffusing information
through time it's a great way of kind of
like moving information around
um and there's also an interesting
difference between recursive and
recurrence
um they're different computational
models entirely now Yan lacun recently
tweeted saying that
there's a big problem with auto
regressive language models and it's
because of these exponentially diverging
trajectories and because he said they
accumulate so much error they're not
really the path forward as well as the
computational limitations of having to
run them sequentially so it's almost
like remarkable that language models and
diffusion models work at all I mean why
do they work and why is there not mode
collapse for example yeah I think that's
a really good point it's it's a miracle
that they work as well as they do I
think if you ask people you know at the
start of the GPT Revolution whether they
thought in five years time we would be
looking at something we're talking about
as AGI I don't think many people would
say that that would be the case you know
you might be able to in some small part
produce text perhaps on a smaller domain
but to say that it's a general AGI is
quite remarkable I think this this stuff
shouldn't be possible you know I think a
lot of what we're what we base our
societal Norms on assumes that
you can't predict text well enough to
mimic intelligence as you mentioned you
know recurrence and I think it's a
really interesting dichotomy between
generative models and discriminative
models
um and actually I like to think of
generative models almost as
the limits of a discriminative model
where you know T goes to zero and you're
collapsing everything to just
understanding the data rather than
trying to predict something into the
future Transformers they almost collapse
at the zero but they're just trying to
predict one step ahead so that it's kind
of falling over itself and and
constantly trying to predict one word at
a time and who would have thought that
you know just predicting one word ahead
could mimic intelligence and four people
I think that's the shock here that's
what's
it's not a particular model type or a
particular way of thinking about AI it's
the fact that very very simple
prediction can lead to something that we
are fooled by as as AGI and I know I
don't think we're there yet but I think
what we need to understand is
if this simple idea can get us this far
maybe this is this is a significant
component of a
a more substantial kind of AI
um that you know really just focuses on
on simple ideas like predicting one step
ahead maybe with memory functions built
in or goal-oriented behavior as we're
seeing with things like Auto GPT now and
maybe that will lead to
true AGI you know I don't know whether
that's that's going to be the case but I
think you know what's interesting to see
is that we can get so far with such a
simple idea and it's often the most
elegant ideas isn't it that are the
correct ones um you know we've seen this
with with in the field of physics and
and other other areas where the simple
of the idea the more likely it is to
cause you know huge huge shock waves I
guess across the across the field and
this is just another example of that
yeah I think it was it was a surprise to
everyone and these Auto aggressive
models because there's always a
discussion between connectionist models
and traditional cognitive models or even
like the Von Neumann architecture
because they they have um a separate
addressable memory but now with these
Auto aggressive models it's almost like
the previous iterations become a memory
because they're they're fed back in but
they are still truncated models but
surprisingly they've kind of taught us
that language and even art is schematic
and it's very very predictable and then
there's the philosophy of well you know
if mimicry is sufficiently
indistinguishable from the real thing is
there is there an actual um difference
yeah exactly and I think um you know
we're looking at things like you know
Vector databases now as being that
memory store
um so yeah people are now thinking of
the GPT model as the almost like the um
the action Taker and or how do we how do
we take information from this Vector
database and push it into something new
into the the future but also you know
compression of ideas and compression of
information has always been a a large
problem of creating intelligence because
um you know it's it's often the case
that we're well we are bombed bombarded
with information and we have to decide
as humans how much of this do we want to
store how much do we want to throw away
what do we want to compress it down into
um do we need to compress it so much
that it doesn't really matter if we
can't decompress it into perfect
information is that good enough to
survive
um and so we're coming up with exactly
the same problem now with uh with auto
aggressive models and Transformers you
know how much do we want to take
previous memory of what's been said
um and store this as part of a
compressible vector that you can then
just reference at inference time
um obviously too much compression and
you you you destroy the very nature of
what you're trying to remember and then
not enough and you've you've you've
bloated your memory full of things that
you don't need to remember at all so I
think what's going to be interesting is
this blend between the
um the creative and almost action taking
GPT style decoder model and static
memory Stores
um we're starting to see in companies
like Pinecone
um with Vector databases really
yeah I start to take the Forefront of
this and say look this is how you need
to as a company start working with GPT
models because they are you know they
are limited in their nature of their
context window so you know as a company
it's all very well to sort of just
prompt a GPT and get a response but
ultimately there needs to be some sort
of store of your company's information
so that you can actually pull you know
live information from a database
um and the the interplay between this
and the the large language model is
going to be super interesting I think
going forward
yeah and interesting so there's always
been this philosophical divide between
go fight people who thought that
knowledge must be certain it must be a
causally determined model and they say
that's how science works you deduce new
facts when you have a causally
determined model and now we're in this
this slightly different philosophy which
is a probabilistic philosophy and we can
store lots of information we can
retrieve it from vector vector databases
we can do retrieval augmented generation
and we're doing very kind of
probabilistic it's kind of Maximum
likelihood estimation as well I mean
we'll talk about energy-based models and
yeah gbt works and so on but
um but we we get these results that are
very very lifelike they mimic
intelligence but they are we know they
are kind of like paradigmatically
different right yeah exactly and I think
you know when we look back
maybe five ten years down the road I
wonder how much of what we consider to
be The Cutting Edge will still be
Transformer and decoder star models and
how much will have swung towards the
symbolic
um you know expression of intelligence
that's that's uh you know I guess
promoted by the Gary Marcus and so on
where they're saying look we need
something else here this isn't enough we
can't just probabilistically
um you know stochastically jump our way
to intelligence we have to in some way
have a store that we seem to have as
humans where we can't make the mistake
of if someone says give me a hundred
cities in the UK or towns beginning with
the letter
um s we can't make a mistake on three of
them because it's obvious to us and so
um it's it's not something that we would
even make with a tiny percentage
probability and the challenge I guess
with probabilistic models is that they
will always have they will always assign
some non-zero probability even to the
most the least likely events and it
seems that we don't we seem to be able
to zero probabilities now what mechanism
we use to do that we don't really know
um you know we've obviously built up
neural networks by and large as a model
of how things work in the brain and I
know many people would say you know
they're very different and that's true
and how the brain works and how neural
networks work out fundamentally
different but there's it's undeniable
there are parallels and so you know we
as as neural networks work out of the
box there is no way to easily zero a
probability without some sort of forcing
of that information onto the model they
will back propagate error but not to the
point where you're going to ever you
know push a zero probability out to a
particular output node so you know how
do we how do we build this in there
needs to be new ideas I think that come
to generative modeling to actually push
the hard factual information into the
model without it being purely
probabilistic yeah yeah and I think this
gets to the core the miracle of human
cognition is that the word is actually
infinite as Chomsky said there's no such
thing as the probability of a sentence
and um but there is there is a Surface
so we have the ability to construct an
abstract World model and what we're
basically doing is is we're discarding
this this Infinity right the the domain
is infinite and um and that's kind of
like what energy-based models do they're
a very clever a way of like taking
something which is very large and
representing it as an unnormalized
probability distribution so Gary Marcus
would say well a GPS is really good
because it has an abstract World model
and that world model um you know it
might still be a probabilistic one but
ideally let's say it's a causally
determined model
we can just create these models on the
fly all over the place now people have
said that large language models are a
theory of linguistics and in in a way
they are right because they have learned
to structure the world that we live in
into this representation space and it's
very very useful but it doesn't really
answer the question of is there an
intelligible symbolic decomposition of
the world that could be derivable in a
similar way and even if it existed would
we understand it and would it be useful
yeah I think there's a couple of things
to sort of mention there first of all
isn't it interesting that language seems
to be a mechanism through which we can
very very accurately
more so than you would think from a
stream of tokens describe the complexity
of reality and does that maybe speak to
a deeper truth about what language is is
it necessary for intelligence maybe it's
so maybe
maybe we've always thought that language
comes out of us being a species that is
intelligent and the causality is that
way but what about if it was the other
way what about if language is a
necessary component for True
intelligence and the reason is that we
can to be intelligent it is necessary to
be able to decompose reality into a
stream of tokens
um you know I think that's a really
interesting idea is that you know we've
always sort of seen language and
Linguistics as a an offshoot of
intelligence and that we need to first
of all understand intelligence and then
we'll understand how language works and
why we why babies learn language the way
they do but what if we need to
understand language first and that will
give us I think what we're seeing now is
that gives us secrets to intelligence
that were previously hidden
um you know we're always doing this the
other way around we still haven't
understood intelligence but we're
suddenly really making strides in
language generation and that is
has suddenly shown this Spotlight onto
what intelligence is that previously
wasn't there
um so that that's the first thing I
think you know which way around is the
causality
um but then yeah also
the point I made just before around how
how much of reality can be actually
truly represented by a stream of tokens
even though we live in a
three-dimensional spatial World from one
time Dimension that we can compress this
into a effectively a one-dimensional
line of tokens
um
and that there is enough of that
captured by that stream that we can we
can decompress that into using our own
brains into back into what reality looks
like to us we can read things and it
really does give the impression of true
reality
um so I think what's going to be
interesting in future
you mentioned World models so at the
moment we've got a very very strong
World model called gbt4 and that world
model is based on a world where only
tokens exist there is no notion of
objects there's no notion of uh time
there is no notion of uh movement action
observation it's just a stream of
integers effectively that's it
so what happens if we apply the same
technology and the same
Theory where the medium through which it
is operating isn't tokens and integers
and text but what if we throw other
things into the mix so we seem to as
humans not treat Vision as a stream of
tokens and obviously a lot of models
these days don't necessarily tokenize
the input
but you know can we build a wall a world
model
that isn't just and this goes back to
Lincoln's point I think he wants to
build wild models that are incredibly
Rich so that the the the decoding if you
like of you know something like a GPT
doesn't operate on tokens but it opens
on a much richer understanding of the
environment
um and I think action taking is
something that I think is going to
become in the next five years something
extraordinarily important to all aspects
of what we consider AI to be at the
moment GPT doesn't have anything to say
about action taking Beyond well treat it
like another token
and you can play a game within GPT
because it just treats everything as
tokens but do we need to treat actions
taking separately do we need to really
think about this as a different
mechanism through which
um we embed information and receive
information from large language models
so yeah I I think you're right though
that you know it's the the relationship
between language and reality is much
tighter than we thought you know it's
not doesn't seem to just be a
um a happy offshoot of you know
intelligence that we you know it's
wonderful that we can all talk it seems
to be a necessity it seems to be
something that's really important to and
give give the impression of true
intelligence so
who knows where that's going to lead but
so much to think about there I know um
it seems to be so important it might be
almost platonic or something very
primitive and exactly very very deep
about it
um I wanted to touch on a couple of
things you said I mean first of all I'm
a big fan of lacoon and his japa
architecture you know we've done lots of
shows on all of his stuff but he's
always had this idea of using
self-supervised learning and um
deliberately creating a rich
representation space because he said as
soon as you supervise um there's a
wonderful image in his Dino paper where
he kind of like showed the richness of
the representation space becoming
truncated but unfortunately as soon as
you fine-tune a model even to perform
actions you you suffer this similar
truncation on the representation space
and I wanted to talk a little bit about
what you were saying before which is
that
um we think of language as being a
little bit extra a bit like Dave David
Chalmers thinks of Consciousness as
being a little bit extra and um early
neuroscientists like Paul McLean thought
of the parts of the brain as being kind
of like a bit like geological geological
strata that you had the old monkey brain
and now you've got this neocortex on the
top and it works in isolation well it
doesn't they're all very tightly
entangled and it's the same thing with
language that um we've now got this
amazing research that
um can
um project you know like we can look at
the representations of subjective States
like colors they're very similar to how
we represent colors and that shows that
there's a kind of bi-directional
entanglement between language and our
subject of experience and um so it's
quite difficult really for us to
separate language from any other type of
experience but what we do know is that
animals clearly think without language
right so um yeah it's I I think it also
gets into this semantics point in in
general which is um like there's some
wonderful research from
um Celeste kid she's a psychologist she
did this study about
um what do people understand as the
concept of a penguin and she asked loads
of people and and she asked some very
very clever questions about comparing
Penguins to other things and she noticed
that there were about 50 clusters I
think so people understand penguins in
different ways and um this all points
down to we we represent Concepts as a
symbol and a concept is just a bag of
analogies and we think we're
communicating and having a common
understanding but we're really not right
you know and that's the reason why
people argue with each other we have
very very different understandings and
that's because we all have semantic Maps
between Concepts and our world model
yeah I think you know if I look at my
own eight-month-year-old daughter now
and I'm always amazed at how much she
seems to be taking on in the world
without necessarily having the
expression back to
to kind of represent that her own way so
you're you're right I think that you
know people whether it's Penguins or or
otherwise have different ways of
representing the same concept and that
will depend hugely on a person's own
experience it will depend on their own
ability to
um to take on information
but then I think as well we need to also
think how does that reflect on AI and
the question of you know what data sets
AI is trained on is obviously critical
because that will that will depend that
will that will necessarily
um inform their own representation of a
particular subject and I think we're
seeing this now with you know the
questions coming up around
data and how it how it's being used
within AI model should be more
transparent because you're right that
the representations that are being
formed are necessarily a function of the
data that it's been trained on whether
that's human or AI
um so yeah I think you know it's really
interesting I saw a comment as well from
Francois Chalet the other day saying
about how his
um how his son was able to you know with
so few examples of the the concept in
the real world be able to point to say a
ghost on the page of his book without
ever seeing a ghost in that particular
form
um now how does that happen that's
something that is quite remarkable isn't
it that we can maybe see a handful of
examples of what a ghost is and even
fewer where it's labeled and still
whether through super self-supervised
learning or otherwise
be able to map that onto new information
into the future I don't think we really
have an answer to that at the moment
even through you know the large language
models and the like
um to have that level that level of
um few shot or zero shot learning
um they're very good large language
models a certain kind of a few shot or
or uh or zero shot learning but I think
to introduce a completely new concept
um
in so much noisy information we have to
remember that you know large language
models are still being prompted with a
effectively a 1D flow of of integer
tokens whereas humans are being
bombarded with
five sensors they're being bombarded
with noise there's a huge amount of
um they need to understand what to pay
attention to and what not and I think
we've seen how this works in large
language models where we need to pay
attention to this stream of tokens but
how do you do that when you have five
streams of sensory information coming in
um some in multiple dimensions and where
do you as a as a human place your
attention when it might be an absolutely
tiny fraction of the visual domain that
needs to need your attention such as
that one image of a ghost
um how do you not how do you not
correlate that with the bird that's
currently tweeting outside and Link
those two together why is that not
important but your father or mother
pointing at that and saying the word
ghost is important we're nowhere near
really understanding these questions we
have a a glimpse of what might be
involved but we're right at the start of
the journey I think it's it's
fascinating to see how it all develops
in the future yeah and it's a topic that
fascinates me we talk about it all the
time and um
first of all that there is a space of
cognition so there's many different ways
of thinking and the models that we've
built clearly are doing thinking right
that they're remarkable
indistinguishable but um we speak about
the Chinese room argument and that's all
about the resolution of understanding so
um my mate Mark Bishop he gives this
example of the guy in the room laughing
so he has this conscious experience
and but you know even then
it's a joke written in Chinese he
understands the joke so just
understanding the joke GPT already does
that you can show GPT a meme you know
why is this picture weird oh it's weird
because it's like a guy playing the
piano on the back of a taxi yeah so GPT
understood the joke but GPT didn't laugh
exactly so does that conscious
experience affect your understanding
Mark Bishop which would say yes it does
but yeah the remarkable thing is we
always thought well multi-modality it's
going to change everything when we've
got different senses and so on and we
know this is true because when you know
like Paris to me I think of I think of
sipping the cappuccino in the brasserie
the times I've been to Paris but these
models don't have that experience they
just have language and they still have a
remarkable you know in Big Air quotes
theory of mind like why is that do you
care do you think it's important I do
think it's important and I've read as
well articles that have said in it's not
just about laughing but it's about
laughing to oneself and
not doing it for someone else and I
think this is what's missing from GPT
and other large language models as well
um or any sort of AI model that's that's
considered to be generative is the idea
that
it has some sort of reason to do things
and it's not just doing things because
it's been prompted but there is some
underlying prior
that
it has a an inclination to move towards
and
you know we're starting to see sort of
things that sort of try to try to push
us towards this Direction with the auto
GPT and other mechanisms that allow
goal-oriented Behavior
but that's still different in my opinion
there's nothing really there's no want
about it it's just a it's doing what
it's always been asked to do which is
predict the next word
so why does it feel different for us
that you know a want or a desire or a
fear or a hatred or a
um or a misunderstanding of that of ours
feels different than just
producing text
um so whether we can use the same
mechanisms to
to give the impression or mimic these
emotions I'm not sure
um because I think that there's
something
it feels like this isn't just a uh a
decoding problem as as GPT is solving
but there needs to be something more
inherent to these models that you know
we're currently lacking um we must
remember that the GPT has one trick its
trick is to predict the next word and I
think you know when when people you know
I see on on Twitter you know people
talking about you know AGI Revolution
and where these models are going to take
over the world and that there's they're
going to run away and they're going to
start thinking for themselves
I think we know we must ground ourselves
always in the fact that we've built a
next word predictor a very very good one
but still that is what we've built and
we need to always remember that there's
no you know that we should it's funny
isn't it no sci-fi has been written
about a an AI that can predict the next
word that it's always an embodied AI or
it's always and yet we're still talking
about these models as
the thing we should fear and that it's
going to cause the end of humanity
so yeah let me let me push back on that
tiny bit I mean I'm interviewing uh
Robert Miles next Sunday he's like a big
alignment AGI guy yeah and um I I think
at this stage it is an over
trivialization to say that they're
predicting the next word and they don't
have a world model and um you know we
are bred on this idea of emergence so um
these alignment folks talk about
orthogonality which is that even though
we're training it to predict the next
word it has These instrumental goals
which emerge and there's an
orthogonality between capability and
perplexity so you know perplexity seems
to go down in this nice exponential
curve but suddenly you get these
emergent capabilities and um and also
there's like intrinsic goals which
emerge versus in something like Auto GPT
where I say I want you to make me a
react app and want it to have an
internet connection I want it to do this
and I wanted to do that and then you get
into this alignment problem which is
what they talk about and this is a real
problem with Jeep with auto GP
um it's almost hilarious I don't know if
you've seen some videos of it but you
you get it to ask like what gaming PC
should I buy and it goes into this
infinite Loop yeah so I need to go do
this I need to go and do that and that's
because like it's so brittle yeah so GPT
is amazing when like I use it all the
time software but I supervise it step by
step because I'm constantly keeping it
on guard rails and that's why I think
people who are hyping Auto GPT don't
really know much about software
engineering for sure to be honest but
but yeah I mean what what do you think
about at this point though do you think
or do you agree that it's an over
trivialization to say they're just
predicting the next word well so the
point about world models that you make I
think is is a important one to fix on
for a little bit I would say they don't
have an explicit World model as in we
haven't we haven't built them to have a
world model but they seem to have
developed one that's that's the critical
point here
um and so I guess the point I'm making
is that what if we do have we do build
them to have an explicit World model and
that goes back to the kin's work on
jeppa is that he would like these these
uh these models to have some thought
some form of explicit World model so
that yes that large language modeling
may form part of this solution that he's
building but I think his point is that
he doesn't want them to just be large
language models that we implicitly seem
to have developed with a world model and
I completely agree with you that you
know they are doing some sort of
reasoning they are doing some sort of
um world modeling but in a way that
they seem to have developed on their own
and I think in some ways that's actually
a more powerful way of building a world
model because do we really want to to
force our
understanding of what a world model
might be onto these models or should we
let them discover that from for
themselves
um so so yeah I think the world mobile
point is an important one and it goes
back to David Haas 2018 Work World
models which is in the book actually
um one of the reasons I wrote the book
was that paper I was fascinated by the
idea that you could hallucinate you know
environment and
um you could learn within that
environment in a way that's just as
powerful as the the real one and that
the fact that there's a vae variation
Auto encoder at the very heart of that
is so critical to its its power
and I think that you know we've seen
five years of progression now and we're
still talking about world modeling as
being the future of generative AI
especially through people like Lincoln
could I push back on that kind of Exodus
we interviewed um David ha and uh I
think I remember that paper and and um
there's some related work from Schmidt
Hoover as well yeah it's jointly written
I think yeah yeah and I think even in
that work they were used they were kind
of taking actions on the um the implicit
representation space but but also more
broadly even with Lagoon's work if you
have a neural network like let's say
it's a world model about what the
environment would be if I took you know
what would the state be if I took this
next action like is that really a world
model it isn't that just as implicit as
a language model I've always sort of
defined a world model as something that
doesn't you don't you build without a
particular task in mind
um you just want to understand how the
world responds to certain inputs so
yeah the the link I guess is back to
Childhood imitation learning where they
are
they are trying to trying to enact in
the world responses that they can
predict through their own world model
and it goes back to I guess friston's
work on active inference around what
we're trying to do perhaps is just align
our prior understanding of how the world
behaves to our posterior and after an
action is taken do we see what we think
we're going to see and how powerful that
idea is can that get us to further
towards intelligent Behavior so yeah I
think in terms of world modeling I think
the first thing I think you know people
who want to understand this is to really
have a tight definition in their mind of
what a world model is we know we're
trying to build something here that is
Task independent we're trying to build
something that you can you can you can
train without any particular
um any particular reward function for
example reinforcement learning often you
know there's a reward function that you
you optimize towards World modeling says
no just train yourself to have a very
very good understanding about how the
world develops given your your actions
and again friston's work talks about
action and perception as two sides of
the same coin
and that actually perhaps our the way in
which we observe and act in the world is
all working towards the same objective
function which is to minimize free
energy and to
um to try to to try to make sure our
generative World model is as accurate as
possible so that we can we can
um contemplate in our own minds how the
future might look and therefore work
towards goals
um I think there's a ton of things to
unpack Within These within these ideas
that you know no no one theory of mind
at the moment has it all correct and
that I think they've probably all got
things that we we need to as as genitive
AI practitioners take notice of and that
we shouldn't just get obsessed by
something like GPT and sort of treat it
as the answer to everything interesting
yeah um so I had a great chat with
Kristen recently and
um as a refresher for folks he's got
this idea of a cybernetic Loop and a
cybernetic Loop is basically what you
just said it's just I have an agent and
I take actions and I get percepts in and
um he really leans on this idea of there
being a didactic exchange his his words
not mine he uses flowery language
um but but this idea of of having this
um collective intelligence of agents
that are demarcated by boundaries and
they have this
um cyclic causal dependency basically
and you get this emergent
self-organization and interesting
Behavior but he is an extreme empiricist
like Lagoon and what I guess what I'm
saying with this world model is it's an
implicit World model because
um it's in it's empirical it's
behavioral so you're you're just taking
actions you're taking in perceptual
making observations and you're building
an implicit World model and then there's
the question of well what is the world
model and there's a really good I'm
blanking on the name of this board game
but there is a great paper out about a
month or two ago where they got a
language model to play a board game
Cicero was that the diplomacy perhaps no
oh the different one that was good as
well yeah that was good as well but they
then they took the representation space
of the language model and um like using
Disney or something oh yeah and it had
this topology which was clearly some
kind of abstract representation of of
the world model not too dissimilar to
what us humans would build because the
key question is you know from an
empiricism point of view is it possible
to go from observational data to an
abstract World model yeah and I think it
comes down to the question of what we
consider an observation
um you know our own actions our
observations ultimately and that's where
I think Kristen's work
um incorporates this idea of action and
percept being two sides of the same coin
in that you know we have on our
shoulders a head that has a has a way of
viewing the world and that we can decide
through action what observation we want
to take in
um so therefore we shouldn't just treat
action as observation as to
um completely separate Concepts but
perhaps we should say well you know our
future observations are and therefore
our future uh successes are dependent on
how we decide to act not just to achieve
a goal but to maximize our information
um input through moving this thing on
our shoulders in the way that makes the
information most valuable to us in the
short and long term
um and I think there's this always been
this trade-off isn't it in reinforcement
learning between exploitation and and uh
exploration and there have been with RL
many uh ways of tackling this some more
hard-coded than others whether you have
a small Epsilon chance of taking a
explorative action is the basic way to
do it but then you have other means of
curiosity learning and so on and so
forth that uh that sort of embed into
the model A a reward for being curious
if you like but there's they still
ultimately a rewards they're all reward
oriented methods and I think what I've
always been seeking especially you know
through researching this book and
looking for in literature is the idea
that we can be reward free because we
seem as humans to be completely happy
living in a world and being intelligent
without any explicit rewards nature
isn't so kind to us as to give Us
rewards for doing things that uh we seem
to enjoy and and want we just have this
mechanism of
being able to through some sort of
self-supervised world model ultimately
tell you know whether something is in
the future as we expect it to be or not
and if you boil it down to it this is
what friston's idea is I think is that
he's like well what do you expect us to
do what can we do if we have a Markov
blanket around us what do you expect a
thing with a Markov blanket to do and
really if you think about it hard the
only thing it can do is is get things
right about its future
and that that's a fundamental idea I
think that
you know even if you think of something
like GPT that is all it's doing it's
getting something right about its future
it's trying to be at one step ahead of
of itself all the time
um so I I do hope that there's a
collision of ideas from you know the
generative eye that we're seeing today
from open Ai and other you know large
companies and the more Niche area of
active inference and Kristen's work
because I I you know I do wonder if the
same amount of money and time was poured
into the concept of active inference
which I think has always been
fascinating and an elegant way to
describe intelligence whether there is
there is a lot of
um benefit of those two Fields really
understanding each other in great depth
and I wonder how many people in
generative modeling uh on the on the
large language model side really
understand active inference and also
vice versa I think there's some great
that Venn diagram space the the
intersection of those two is going to be
a really interesting area to explore
going forward yeah I mean since we're on
the the subject of of Briston so um yeah
he's
the main thing that he solved is this
kind of what is normally a dichotomy
between exploration and exploitation so
he's got this beautiful formalism and he
calls it energy and entropy I think the
the entropy is basically like a kind of
KL Divergence it's just a way of
comparing probability exactly yeah but
but the the idea is is that there's this
existential imperative and you're kind
of like
um predicting the the likelihood of your
existence if you take this trajectory of
paths and he Compares that with what he
thinks to be quite naive um value-based
learning in reinforcement learning which
is you know that you do
um something which is equivalent to
maximum likelihood estimation through a
value function and um and it gets to it
gets to the heart of kind of goal-based
learning versus value-based learning but
could you just sketch out exactly what
is the difference between friston's
ideas and reinforcement learning and
computationally perhaps why is it
difficult to implement for instance I
did well yeah so let's start with
reinforcement learning I think the
diagram that you see in just about every
reinforcement learning book summarizes
it neatly which is that you have two
considered separate entities the agent
and the environment and there is no the
two can be completely modular so that
one doesn't depend on the other and what
I mean by that is that there's this
exchange of information that happens
between them uh the agent giving actions
to the environment and the environment
given observations and rewards back to
the agent and are done states which
again is completely uh if you think
about it arbitrary I mean we don't have
a done state in reality do we so already
you're in problems with
um considering reinforcement learning as
the the real mechanism through which
actual human learning takes place
because reward done States I mean we
don't have these things in reality we
just get the stream of observations so
active inference sort of treats it
differently and it says well what if we
just have this stream of observations
and there is some prior distribution
that we're looking to move towards
um of our own internal hidden latent
representation and what we're going to
try and do is do this via a
non-reward-based mechanism so the only
reward is really our own internal
perception of whether we're able to how
good our generative model is effectively
and our generative model is just you
know given things that I can do in the
environment am I able to show what is
going to happen in future
um and you know there's two ways of
thinking about that you can either do it
in the observation space itself and so
compare a decoded observation if you
like based on your own representation to
the actual or you can do everything in
latent space
um
and you know something like uh I guess
it's the same difference I guess between
the early diffusion models which are all
um based in observation space and
something like latent diffusion where
the diffusion model actually happens
within latent space
and so yeah the the the two the two
really differ on the idea that
um the the agent and the the environment
have this exchange of information on
reinforcement learning side via rewards
and and actions and you end up trying to
maximize a A or minimize in some cases a
loss function a maximize reward or
minimize um a negative reward and on the
other side on active inference you're
always looking to
to optimize the generative model and it
ends up being that the generative model
itself is the the be all and end-all of
the the existence and that you know the
Markov blanket is only intact if the
generative model stays good and so as
soon as you destroy the Markov blanket
you destroy your existence and you're no
longer an interesting entity within that
environment
um and yeah I think that's a beautiful
idea and I I just I'm very honored
actually that Carl Kristen's um provided
a forward to the new edition of the book
he's an absolute hero of mine so
um I'm looking forward to seeing how the
two Fields overlap in future
yeah yeah
um friston is absolutely amazing and um
you know I run the show with Keith and
Kristen is Keith's favorite but the the
thing is um in an Ideal World we would
all be bayesians right and it works so
well and we'll talk about by the way the
the Divergence between traditional data
science and what we're doing now with
with the big stuff but
um it's it's one of the main
um tools in the Box as a data scientist
to be doing Bayesian optimizational
gaussian processes and you know it's
because it gives you this beautifully
principled way of knowing about areas of
uncertainty and knowing where you need
to explore and Kristen combine those
together into a um you know in into a
single formalism but um we live in a
world which is very complicated right so
we can't possibly I mean there is no
such thing as a probability distribution
over everything lacoon took the move of
inventing these energy-based models but
is it not a significant restriction to
implementing
um friston's ideas as well yeah I think
that's always been the challenge with
active inference is that it's found
difficulty in actual application to a
specific complex problem so toy examples
are you know are very important to
demonstrate the concept but I think
where other kinds of modeling such as
the GPT models have succeeded is that
they've been trained on huge amounts of
data and they're able to solve very
complex problems now that's not to say
that the idea is
the active inference idea is is
incapable
but I would say I you know it needs real
attention in order to
in order to map these same ideas onto
something more complex
um I I mean I would love to know I don't
have a huge amount of information on
what is happening in active inference
right now but I imagine this is one of
the key problems that is being looked at
is how do you map these ideas which are
so elegant and so beautiful to something
that actually has practical application
and isn't just takes it Beyond we
remember as well
the same thing was true of a lot of the
uh the early you know what we consider
neural network architectures now that
are Cutting Edge in that you know they
could be worked on toy examples but
people would say yeah but you know they
can't just take in the entire web and
learn how to predict into the future
well they can you know they just needed
a huge amount of investment from a few
key companies so
I don't think there's anything in
principle stopping the same ideas being
applied active inference ideas being
applied at scale but it needs needs
attention you know it needs
um attention is probably the wrong word
there to I mean that in a non-technical
sense rather than a Transformer sense
but well who knows maybe it does need
attention in a Transformer sense as well
but yeah we we just need
I guess I I guess what I'd love to see
is that there's a um a real push towards
combining these ideas because I think
they've both got things to say and quite
different things to say in many many
cases but that there is overlap and that
some of the ideas from active inference
can start bleeding through into
Transformers and and GPT star models
um
yeah it's an interesting area to sort of
see develop I think it is yeah and we're
speaking with Maxwell ramstead in a few
weeks he's really um like a big pillar
in that Community but yeah and I was
trying to get to the bottom of this with
Tristan because it's um you can you can
use the model as a as a simulator or as
a you know a simulacrum which basically
means that I can simulate the world and
even then I could start from the lowest
possible like you know the highest
resolution which isn't really going to
work so usually you have to you have to
select a level of coarseness that you're
going to start from um just to reduce
the size of of the problem so you might
pre-define the agents and the boundaries
and you might reduce the size of of the
approximation space in in some way
um or you can just use it as a lens to
understand the world as it is that's the
simulacra and um it's it's actually
quite brittle in both cases to get any
friction with the real world right
because I've built this AI simulation
well how do I actually usefully use that
in the real world or I'm using it as a
lens to understand you know like
um collective intelligence and emergence
Dynamics and Twitter and Society how do
I use that in the real world so it's a
similar thing with um you know the using
simulators and reinforcement learning
there's not much friction with the real
world so I think that's the main
challenge that they need to overcome
yeah another area I think to start on as
well is the idea of uh there being
multiple agents in the same environment
where no one agent has all the
information but they have a mechanism to
share information between agents and
I suppose with you know with with things
like GPT they all only really care and
they have been trained to care about
their own you know one interpretation of
this data set there is only one gpt4
model but it's interesting to think how
you know as a human I mean just the
thought experiment if there is only one
human in existence with the same that
was born
how much could they really learn if it
was just them do they need other humans
with other experiences
in order to develop to the highest
levels of intelligence that we're you
know we see around us um I don't know
whether that idea is something that is
going to also bleed into uh into into
this sort of Transformer and and
um you know decode a Transformer style
uh AI I don't know whether you know they
will start talking to each other and
therefore learning information from them
and that we won't try to build one super
intelligence that has seen everything
and can reason about everything but what
about if there were smaller models
trained on smaller data sets where
they are able to develop an
extraordinarily high level of
understanding about their field and that
they have the mechanism to engage with
other agents that have done the same
thing about other data sets and that
that is how as a superset we develop
intelligence and that no one of them on
their own is able to to to say yes I am
the super intelligence I mean I think
that's an interesting area as well isn't
it that we might sort of see
proliferate is that the idea that we
might have a an um on top of a strata of
human existence there may be an
undercurrent of AI models all also
speaking to each other and engaging
within information and engaging with
each other and delivering information
between each other and also between
between strata so to us and from us
um and I think I wonder if that's one of
the areas that we might start to see
developing is that we don't just have
one company trying to build one model to
understand everything but there are
there are different models that have
different Specialties and that there is
some sort of interface between them
probably natural language through which
they can share and and want and this is
where the wanting comes in they need to
want to to share information now how do
you embed that
um
you know because this is this is at the
point of inference remember this isn't
we can't train them further uh you know
once they're out in the wild they have
to this want has to come from some sort
of internal internal function
and so
why should they want to care to talk to
this GPT model rather than this GPT
model over here so yeah I I'm just
thinking out now out loud now sort of
how that might happen I don't know
fascinating though isn't it like why
don't we do that well that's exactly
what Ben Gertz has been advocating for
years with his Singularity net and we
interviewed him at the time and the
problem is
um not only relevance and the the
interface is a problem because you have
the semantics problem
um it's very very brittle it's very very
difficult to have a specification of an
API that can be dynamically discovered
and consumed by others but then there's
also some kind of a reputation system I
might want to consume this API over
another API and in principle I think
it's a really good idea because I love
this idea of collective intelligence and
decentralized intelligence I don't want
to have one single monolithic model but
by the same token when you start talking
about hybrid architectures it introduces
a form of brittleness I mean the main
reason why neural networks aren't
brittle is because they do end-to-end
learning which over came a lot of the
brittleness of traditional software
engineering where you have all of these
modules with interfaces and so on but um
but that was exactly what Rams did and
foreston kind of spoke about in in their
recent paper which this idea of an
intelligence 3.0 this new Society of of
kind of like intelligent agents that
that have these
um didactic exchanges are going to use
his language but um there are a couple
of issues that come up in my mind and I
asked Bristol about this which is to say
like
um if you did have such an um like a
nebulous amorphous domain of
intelligence and first of all society's
already like that right so we already
have the info sphere
um no nobody understands how it works
it's kind of diffused and lots of agents
and systems that are interconnected but
increasingly a lot of those agents will
themselves be more intelligent than they
are now and from a kind of regulatory
point of view and ethics point of view
how do we apply pressures
um we can't predict the future because
of those exponential trajectories but
you know some people might say well we
need to apply these pressures to kind of
stop bad things from happening in the
future I mean what what are your
thoughts on that yeah I mean it's a
really a really um important subject but
also one that's incredibly nuanced I
think the ethical side of things because
on the one hand I can completely
understand why you know people would be
would be concerned that we don't seem to
have any sort of Regulation or body that
oversees the development of AI models in
the same way that we do with
um I mean it's been talked about for
example nuclear energy or Nuclear
Physics
um so you know how do we ensure that
what we're building isn't actually
incredibly destructive but on the other
hand I think in order to make sure that
the regulation is as tight as possible
we need to stay on top of you know what
these models are doing and that requires
research and it requires us not to pause
as that the letter obviously was
advocating for
um so I think in terms of Ethics I what
I would like to see is that there is a
certain amount of openness about data I
think data is really really critical to
to understand what we're training the
models on and also to for example for
somebody to be able to to understand if
if a particular piece of data is within
a model or without or not within a model
and I can understand why companies want
to make you know keep this information
private
um but ultimately you know we are the
models are a reflection of the data
they're trained on so we can't really
just shun that responsibility of saying
well you know it's it's private and it's
hidden so you know it is as it is I mean
we you can't say the same thing about
food that we eat we want to know what's
in it and I you know I wonder if there's
a parallel there to be drawn about you
know it's not about sort of saying
exactly how something was made or saying
something exactly the process but at
least that you have to understand
what it is we're consuming
um and I always I I like to see AI as a
tool I don't like to see it as a source
and I think sometimes people
you know when they're talking about AI
they sort of they say oh you need to
quote the source as as chat GPT and I
really don't like that because
it assumes that the it starts giving
some some Credence to that particular
entity and saying that this this the
source of the information is chat GPT
and it's not the source of the
information is is ultimately the data
that it's trained on albeit diffused and
combined in a myriad of different ways
that we could never possibly begin to
understand into what we see is that the
creation and it's the AI is the tool
through which that happens it's not the
the the the end point of the information
if you like and so I think ethically we
need to sort of that's how we need to
treat Ai and
we always need to give the we need to we
need to give people the understanding
that when they're using this that
ultimately what it is being what it's
showing us is a reflection of our own
existence in the data that it's been
trained on
um now how we do that from a regulatory
perspective I don't know I mean that's a
yeah I think it starts questioning the
very axioms of our own societal norms
and you know one Axiom is that we you
can't create quantity the quantity that
we're seeing of text at this sort of
scale I think that's sort of something
that a lot of our legal system is based
around
and also our education system is based
around the fact that you you can't just
generate an essay and so it's it's it's
knocked one of these axioms completely
for six because now things like
copyright law are based on the principle
of
the fact that to generate somebody's
content you need to put real effort and
time in to do so and and that the idea
of copying something you know
just
um or even making very small minor
tweaks to it and not putting your sweat
of the brow into it if you like is
considered a a
yeah it is going to be something that
you can't do because you know ultimately
that's not showing any any
transformational process over the work
um but you know now that we have ai
systems that can produce the quantity
and the scale that we're seeing that is
that's calling into question this Axiom
and we need it's not just a tweak to the
system I think we need completely to
overhaul the way that we see things like
copyright and there's been so many cases
of this recently Music Arts literature
um and the reason we can't answer these
questions quickly is because I don't
think it's a quick fix I think it's
probably something we need to think very
seriously about and that the courts will
need to decide how to handle
yeah
um so copyright currently hangs on
effort and skill exactly things that
have been greatly diminished precisely
yeah done by these generative models
yeah I I agree with that I wanted to
push back a tiny bit on the um I mean I
agree with the anthropomorphization and
the the autonomy piece though which is
that when I'm using a model
interactively I kind of agree with you
intuitively that um I'm guiding the
process and it's still my creation
um even with gbt4 I mean you know I
wrote a react app over the weekend and
it was a very iterative process and when
I'm iterating I've actually got this
mental model in my mind there's a kind
of tree structure and I'm kind of
traversing the tree and then it
generates something I don't want I go
one step up the tree I go into you know
I'm guiding the process and the more you
guide the process I think it's a
spectrum like the more you have the
right to say that it's yours but I think
we should accept that these models are
going to be running autonomously and
um how they behave will will be very
complex because they'll be consumed by
different people with situated knowledge
with different
um I don't know in in a different
environment basically and it'll just
produce this very kind of complex array
of of effects on society and then it
gets to the point you were saying about
whether the model should reflect the
world as it is or as we want and even
humans are interesting because we might
just be naive prediction machines but we
also have these emergent like planes of
morality for example so we all kind of
think that okay well this is the way
things are that I actually think it
should be different and this is the way
I behave but internally I have a model
which is slightly different I you know
give out
um externally so um yeah like do do you
think that we should model reality as it
is or do you think we should apply
pressure
yeah I mean I think so the alignment
problem is something I think um you know
Samuel was saying the other day that
it's it's just it's just not solved and
it's a it's a major issue I think for
the you know open AI if they're going to
be
in the future sort of you know seen to
be the the leaders of this field it's
something that they need to solve or at
least they need to show that there are
there are steps being taken towards such
a solution
um I think you know it's really
interesting to you know if we think
about where the problem lies here if
it's just as a thought experiment
imagine we had exactly the same
technology that we have today but it
took instead of seconds to generate text
or images if we were talking about you
know the process of months and and the
the velocity of these models was so much
slower you know would we be seeing them
as so much of a threat and would we'd be
so worried about their alignment to
moral values I think the thing that
scares people is the speed and the
volume and it's not necessarily whether
it's possible it's the fact that it's
possible at speed and at scale
um and I think we need to really be
careful here especially when we're
talking about legislation that it's not
the the fact that it's possible it's the
problem it seems to be it's the fact
that it's possible
um to anybody and scale and a volume and
so
yeah I think when people you know when
they were talking about the pause and
the letter and you know what people were
really saying is that we need to we need
to worry about how how quickly the model
is able to produce content and produce
things like disinformation rather than
the fact that it's able to do it at all
um and so it would be a shame to see you
know legislation sort of ban or in some
way regulate the the model itself
because the model itself isn't really
the problem I think it's the way in
which it's dressed up and packaged
um and so yeah I do wonder if
we need to really understand the nuances
of the problem rather than sort of just
say well all AI
all AI models that produce text you know
are should be should be banned because
obviously we've had these models for a
long time and it's only now that we're
seeing this this proliferation of speed
and scale that it started to become an
issue
um so yeah I don't know if that answers
your question but I think it's really
important to sort of note it's the it's
it's the velocity and the volume that's
the problem not the the fact that it's
possible at all um if that makes sense
yeah um I had a wonderful discussion
with Luciano floridi from the Oxford um
internet Institute and yeah he said the
same thing you know what's really
different now is the scale yeah velocity
but even then you could push back and
say well
um being able to generate this stuff at
scale is not the same as being able to
distribute it at scale so I'm I'm kind
of on the fence a little bit but he gave
this wonderful quote which is that you
know like drop after drop after drop and
18 years later you know the drop kind of
shapes the the drop shapes The Rock
basically and um these these models will
have pernicious effects right over the
over the next 20 years or so they're
going to steer society and you could
just argue well um first of all you
can't really regulate it you can't
regulate language models because this
technology is in the hands of everyone
exactly yeah although it is interesting
doing that open AI for some reason maybe
you've got some intuition on this their
models are significantly better than
everybody else's when I'm when I'm using
language models I mean honestly I only
use gbt4 and yeah we'll talk about some
of them the minor differences but um but
pretty soon this technology will be
democratized every government's going to
create their own one loads of companies
are creating them at the moment so you
can't really stop it right no absolutely
and you're right it's in the it's in the
open source Community now so as soon as
that you know the technology is out
there and in in in the key the important
thing to note about that is that it's
the fact that the technology itself
isn't complex it's not like we're
talking about you know building a
nuclear reactor where it's not everyone
can do this to be completely honest the
technology that drives gpt4 well gpt3 at
least we don't know gpt4 because they
haven't really talked about it very
publicly but certainly gpt3 we're
talking about you know just matrix
multiplication like there's nothing more
to it than than that and you know even
to that extent we're talking about
matrix multiplication where there's no
recurrence there's no convolution
the attention mechanism is remarkably
simple and it's amazing actually it
wasn't discovered before things like
lstms because they are lstms are by far
more complicated to learn about and to
understand
you know attention is a very simple
principle that I think
the this is why we're seeing lots of
replica models now is that really what
you you what you're talking about is can
you can you scale up the compute and can
you have you got enough data and even
then there's the pile there's different
data sets out there that are open to
public consumption so what you're
talking about really is have you got the
um Can you hire can you build the right
team in order to build the structures
for these models and do you have the the
ability to pay for this huge amount of
compute and you know that's coming down
all the time as well so you're
absolutely right that this is becoming
democratized as a technology it's not a
nuclear reactor we're building we're
building something that ultimately is
um it's it's compute at the end of the
day and and I know Sam Altman talked
about the fact that gpt4's improvements
are actually hundreds of minor
improvements rather than a significant
technological leap
and so I think you know why is it so
much better than the other models I
think they've got extraordinarily smart
people working for them at open Ai and I
do think that you know I I would believe
in when he says that it's a lot of minor
improvements rather than a sort of major
change that they've made to the model
architecture
um but is it bigger yeah probably I
would imagine so but I don't know
um I guess yeah you'd have to talk to
someone on the inside open AI but it's
interesting to know that you can make
the significant improvements through
minor changes rather than some sort of
major technological Improvement yeah I
mean there's a few things we can talk
about we can talk about in attention in
general and there's actually a really
interesting um new paper out which
manage managed to scale it up to two
million tokens by
um using an RNN with you know like the
the actual nodes were attention blocks
and then like you know being able to
share information through a meta RNN on
on top
um so yeah there's the question of what
happens when we when we have longer um
attention lengths and I'm not actually
convinced it's a foregone conclusion
that longer attention length is better
at reasoning and better at various
different um things but
um yeah so um first of all the
differences between the GPT model so
even GPT 3.5 we suspect that it must be
a tiny model because for them to deploy
it at scale it's probably like around 2
billion parameters I think people have
estimated and and then I agree with you
it's probably just a very basic instruct
model so it's like a traditional
self-attention Auto aggressive
Transformer that's been fine-tuned with
some kind of like let's say rlhf or
something and probably the secret source
is the the data that they've trained it
on and the human fine tuning
now it's really really good I think gbt
3.5 is actually better than codex
because if you read the Sparks of AI
paper they didn't include GPT 3.5
because I think the reason was it was
actually better than the Codex model but
then the reason why people don't use GPT
3.5 for coding is because it's got a
contact size of 4K which is basically
useless yeah having a contact size of 8K
is is good enough for a lot of things 32
would be even better yeah but then
building and deploying a model with a
contact size of 32k is basically
impossible unless you're open AI so do
you think that'll be a blocker for a
long time yeah and I well I think this
comes back to the idea of you know as
humans we seem to be able to compress
information from our distant past into
something that we can retrieve quickly
at inference time we don't seem to store
in memory or context of our entire
existence what we seem to be doing is
packaging up information into small
units that we can call upon at inference
time so yes I agree there seems to be
some knee for a context window of a
certain size otherwise you your
short-term memory is is severely
impaired
um but you know how do we and I think
this is where the vector database thing
is an interesting idea how do we embed
long contextual information that isn't
just using the attention mechanism or
maybe that attention mechanism can be
used at a higher hierarchical level so
that the units over which attention is
operating aren't tokens and words
anymore but they are Concepts and ideas
and embeddings
um in a higher sort of hierarchical
latent space so
um yeah I think I think that's one
interesting idea uh to explore but also
the the idea there that you mentioned
that you know yeah GPT 3.5 is is as good
if not better than the coding model I
think is yeah just speaks to the idea
that
um the yeah the ability for these models
to understand in detail a range of
different topics is remarkable and they
don't need to be necessarily trained on
a single uh Corpus of text they can sort
of maybe chat you know GPT 3.5 is using
some information from actual natural
language text in order to help its
coding ability and I've read I've read
um as well that that goes the other way
and that logic is in some ways uh is
improved Within These models if they are
trained on code because code is
ultimately our human expression of logic
in text form and so if you train a large
language model on a huge amount of
coding information such as you know the
GitHub database then you actually
generate a language model that is able
to reason a lot more effectively
and so I yeah I think that's a that's an
incredible idea that you can it can sort
of move information from our sort of
messy noisy uh Corpus of of text that is
not coding into something that is that
is coding into something that is
ultimately you know all about logical
reasoning but in in the space of natural
language
yeah exactly and they've I mean
Microsoft basically owns open AI at this
point and they've given them access to
all of the code on GitHub and actually a
lot of providers are now just cottoning
on that they shouldn't be giving their
data away so I think you know stack
Overflow and Reddit and
um Elon Musk with Twitter for example so
in a way gpt4 might be the best we ever
see I mean I I actually believe that
gbt4 might be at the limit of what's
possible with this Paradigm anyway
although I will get you to answer your
intuition on
does it go without saying that a longer
context size is better like I've not
played with the 32k model I don't know
if they're still using like cross
attention I don't know whether it's as
good as the 8K model and it's not a
foregone conclusion that a longer
contact size is better I mean why don't
we just do that one for yeah so briefly
uh context window just just to kind of
cover off what we mean by this is how
far back in the past a model can attend
to and unlike a recurrent neural network
where if information is further in the
past it is more likely to be diluted
because it's currently it's having to
update its hidden State continuously in
sequence as it runs through the text
attention treats all previous tokens as
equal and it can decide where it wants
to focus its attention so even if
something was the 29 999 token that has
as much potential to be brought forward
into the current context as the previous
token
um so it treats them all as equal and it
has the ability to say I want to draw
attention to this word here and then
maybe thousands of words in the future
this particular word and it will pull
those through through layers of
multi-head attention layers
um to ultimately give a probabilistic
prediction of the next word
um so what does a larger context when do
you give you well quite simply it only
gives you the ability to attend to
something that is further back in time
and so to your point there around
you know what do we need longer context
Windows and is that the answer well I
think it's only the answer if you build
if you only build models that are
decoder Transformers that don't involve
any memory as soon as you start talking
about memory and finding ways to embed
um packets of information from the
distant past
then the context window doesn't become
so important and you think about all of
our conversations so far how far does 32
000 tokens get get us back well probably
from the start of our conversation I'm
not remembering exactly what's been said
word for word I've just got a broad
understanding of our introduction and
I've I've my brain seems to have
package that up into a unit that I could
probably tell you roughly what we talked
about but I can't tell you the exact
sentence
um and obviously biologically we're
limited by the um the lump of matter
that's in our heads and there's a
spatial restriction and a weight
restriction which you don't necessarily
have with with
um silicon
um but you know you do have restrictions
in terms of inference time and the
larger the models get the slower they
become like you rightly said and so if
we're going to practically build these
things to be useful to people we do have
uh constraints on size and just like our
you know our brains where the constraint
is is the fact that we need to carry it
around on our heads
um the constraint with large language
models is slightly different it's not
necessarily a weight consideration
obviously but it's a it's a speed
consideration that we need to have so I
think you're right that gpt4 we might be
seeing as the the limit of what we can
do with this context window size perhaps
but there will be now other technologies
that need to be developed alongside the
decoder style Transformer that enable
for us to pull information from the
distant past and Vector databases I
think are one exciting technology that
we're seeing do this but even that the
way you know an embedding effectively
works is it's going to Chunk Up
information into say 150 token chunks
and each of those chunks gets embedded
into a a vector and those vectors are
then compared to the current context
window Vector to say which one do you
think is closest and in many cases we're
talking about things like cosine
similarity it's a fairly rudimentary
ways of comparing vectors with each
other
um but you know that I think you know
there's going to be technological
improvements in how we do that look back
um one way that you know we've just
talked about on on this call is can we
apply the attention mechanism not two
words but to Concepts and perhaps you
know we we have into our past sort of
hierarchical understanding of
you know could I could I summarize in a
year all of my experience and that's one
token and maybe I want to pull just that
one token the year's worth of existence
token into my current context window to
tell you about something that happened
10 years ago I'm not going to go back
and look at every single word but my
brain seems to have
embedded that into some space that I can
retrieve quickly and that's going to be
a lot less detailed than something from
a week in the past and a day in the past
and they may have their own way of being
embedded But ultimately
all of the attention mechanisms that are
used by gbt4 are at the token level as
far as we understand we obviously don't
know but
we understand that the context window is
all is all based around tokens and that
we haven't got the ability to at the
moment sort of pull in a token from 10
years ago at a higher a higher level of
abstraction
so I would love to see research in that
I haven't actually seen any sort of
talking about things that way but yeah
just through this conversation with I
mean it's an interesting idea I think
right that we can apply attention to a
different hierarchies it's similar to
friston's idea that you know active
inference going to be applied at
different hierarchical levels of
existence the organization the organism
itself but also down to the cellular
level and there's Markov blankets around
each of these units well maybe we have
the ability in the future to divide up
um historical experience into chunks
that we tokenize and that we talk about
as something can be embedded in its own
right and that future decoder models
won't just be operating at one level but
they have the ability to spread across
multiple levels of hierarchy I think
that's an exciting area of research yeah
yeah I'm similarly very excited about a
hierarchical approach
um as we just said there's there's
currently this recurrent approach which
fuses information through time but as we
know rnns forget things quite quickly
um but yeah like there's something
really really exciting about large
language models as they are at the
moment because they're so simple and
they're very high resolution so
everything that's in your context
um it can attend to on a token by token
basis but the reason why I think it's
not a foregone conclusion that a longer
context size is better is because we
have a strong locality prior most
machine learning priors are locality
prizes the way we think and just think
about it if you're training a model with
100K context all of the long-range
dependencies will be so sparse as to
have basically zero gradient because
there's exponentially more crap in the
future like the further the further
Horizon The Horizon goes the more crap
there is
um and also it becomes relevant how you
train it because let's say I'm training
on all the data on GitHub well
um the order in which I give the
information to GPT might be relevant
because you know presumably I would
still cluster all of the code files that
are from a particular repo and then you
get into this notion of okay well I
could move away from just showing it
tokens and actually explicitly saying
this is a file and then you made the
move of doing retrieval augmented
generation and Vector search but in my
experience retrieval augmented
generation isn't that good and that's
partially because you lose the beauty of
language models which is that they have
this like very rich semantic map and
understanding at a high resolution when
you start doing a cosine similarity on
on a vector and then pulling random bits
of information and I mean like a lot of
these search engines like Bing that do
this at the moment I mean frankly I
prefer using raw GPT than Bing because
it's exactly a load of crap yep I
completely agree I think you're right
though that you know the way when we're
talking about Vector lookup this works
is that the chunk itself will
um it will will capture it via its
embedding a certain uh a certain flavor
of what that paragraph was about but the
problem with that is that the same
paragraph might have many different
applications into your current context
so that embedding loses a certain amount
of information that you and you don't
have that problem exactly like you said
with um with GPT style models because
the very definition of attention is that
it can decide where it wants to attend
to and you know if you take um that's a
good example in the book of
um you know the Pink Elephant wanted to
get into the car but it was too well
obviously we're thinking big because
it's an elephant and it's a car and he
wants it to get in the word pink has no
relevance there as there's no there's no
contextual benefit in attention to it
but as soon as we say you know the Pink
Elephant wanted to
um wanted to hide then the very fact
that it's colored pink is going to be a
problem because it's very visible in the
environment and so suddenly that work
becomes relevant and we've you know if
we if we were trying to embed this whole
paragraph or this 150 words into an
embedding well we're back to the old
lstm problem of how much how much weight
or how much importance within the
embedding do you want to give the word
pink and it depends on the context so
yeah while Vector databases are one way
to solve this problem I think what I'd
love to see is you know this idea that
that
the perhaps Concepts and and chunks from
the past are how can we how can we
almost create maybe multiple embeddings
of the same of the same idea or create
the embedding somehow on the fly to to
capture you know what we want it to do
in this current context
um yeah I don't think it's an easy thing
to solve but that's uh that's where we
might have to get to okay so how should
schools and universities prepare for the
Advent of generative AI yeah I mean I
used to be a math teacher so I I have
good memories of you know teaching
classrooms full of children and
um I I do worry these days about what
the impactation of these Technologies
are going to be because I don't think I
don't think the sector is ready and I I
mean that in the sense of
but you know speaking with teachers and
speaking with people in in the sector I
get the feeling of
um that the fact that children have the
ability to access this technology now is
not something that's particularly front
and foremost of of people's minds and
you know we're seeing it at University
level as well where people are
submitting essays through chat GPT
and there's huge questions that need
answering whether it should be allowed
whether it should be something that's
encouraged because it actually allows
children and students to generate more
original and perhaps go to areas of
thought that they wouldn't have
previously gone to
um or you know do we do we say actually
these Technologies are taking away the
ability for students to think
independently and how do we what does
education mean you know what's the
definition of education and I think you
know if we look back what the precedent
for this is when you think of the the
invention of the calculator or the
internet itself these are always
technologies that were
worried about as a potential threat to
the definition of education and I think
you know we've moved now from a a time
when road to learning and memorization
was considered the absolute Pinnacle of
somebody's intelligence through to
creative thought and synthesis of ideas
being more important and what we're
seeing now is that even that is under
threat the very synthesis of ideas from
across domains is something that AI can
do and not just assist with but complete
so I think what education needs to do is
have a look at itself and ask what do we
what what do we need to do in order to
ensure that the definition that we of
Education we want to take into the
future is one that is aligned with the
technological capabilities of the age of
the era but also is one that is going to
prepare students for the future
um and they're you know their working
life
yeah I think I think you nailed it so I
would say education is about helping
kids understand as you say at an
abstract level not just memorization
um fostering kind of creativity and
having an inquiring mind now Chomsky
said that language models make you lazy
now I'm really tall on this because
language models have helped me cover
more grounds and learn more stuff than I
would have done but they've changed how
I how I do things right so I'm spending
less attention on things which are
schematic and you know kind of quite
easy to automate and I'm I'm kind of
spending more attention focusing and
learning and exploring things that I
wouldn't otherwise have done but maybe
I'm Different do you think that they're
going to make kids lazy I well I'm
exactly like you and I it's absolutely
it for sure improved how I work I mean I
I don't feel lazier as a result of it I
feel more productive now the question is
if we'd have had this when we were at
school would we be in the position now
to be saying that or would we be more
lazy and less productive and I think
what's important is to realize a
colleague of mine said to me the other
day
the the problem we can't just say we'll
give it to all students because it's
going to make them more productive
because look at us we're productive
we've remembered a world where we've had
to sit down with a blank sheet of paper
and write that essay and so we've I feel
like because we've been through that
process we can take this for that we can
use this technology to its absolute
maximum potential and not not use it as
a crutch
um and you know like you said earlier
about the the tree of going back
revising updating the prompt maybe
adding a bit of your own code in putting
that back into chat GPT these are all
skills we learned because we were there
with that that pencil in front of a our
essay written probably by hand
um putting lines through it Crossing
that bit out moving this paragraph down
and then later with word processors
doing exactly the same thing and the
problem I think with giving children
just carte blanche access to this sort
of technology is that they haven't
developed the abstract skills like you
said up front to be able to be
self-critical to be able to
edit revise cut back words where you
know we're being too wordy AdWords we're
more more is needed and instead they
there is a huge danger of we end up just
being
um users of one particular tool and not
really having control over what's being
generated
so having said that that's one side of
my my brain is thinking you know we
really need to be careful with using
this in the classroom having said that
children will be moving into a world
where every day they're going to be
using this technology it will be
embedded into Microsoft Word it will be
in their messaging apps it will be
um the web itself will be driven through
largely language-based search I think
and so we need to prepare them for that
and so you can't just say well you know
here's your word processor and we're
going to disable all of these when we
don't disable spell checking for example
so yeah we've got to do it in a way I
think that sort of and like we do with
the internet you know just remind
students that there are two ways of
thinking uh one way is on the spot
critical uh thoughts which you don't
have that crutch of Technology around
you in order to come up with ideas
um and then another way which is perhaps
in the same way that we encourage
students to use the internet for
coursework which is longer term
um you know use everything available to
you to produce the most incredible piece
of work and that doesn't just mean
putting it into chat GPT but it means
using it as one tool in Your Arsenal of
different techniques and and uh and
tools to to produce the best of the
piece of work that truly reflects your
opinion or truly reflects your beliefs
and there's a few steps that we can take
I think you know things like written
essays being submitted might end up
being a thing of the past and there will
have to be some sort of viver that goes
alongside it very small thing that we
can do to make make this a less of a
problem immediately
um and like we do with universities you
don't just submit your PhD you have to
defend it and you have to answer
difficult in-depth questions that back
up your your point of view
um and I think it's a great skill anyway
I mean even a chat GPT didn't exist why
don't we do this now with written essays
um but then also I think we need to talk
about there's a body in the UK called
um the jcq I think which is a body that
oversees all examinations and and
um the examining examining boards and
explains to them how they should handle
things like plagiarism or tries to come
up with a a sort of Consolidated list of
approaches and they've released recently
released some advice on AI and you know
how we should be teaching students about
these Technologies
um and having read it I feel that the
spirit of it is is right but I think
some of the points in the execution are
questionable um they sort of talk about
AI as something that needs referencing
so if you've if you for example use as a
student chat GPT to generate your part
of your essay or indeed to use it to
structure it you need to say on your
list of references that chat GPT is a
reference you know like square brackets
five chat GPT for me that's because
first of all as I said earlier we
shouldn't be treating AI as the source
AI is a tool we don't we don't quote
grammarly when we've used that to help
our phrasing or our spelling and I and I
think it's a it's anthropomizing you
know making human I guess if I can say
the word anthropomorphizing
um
the the fact that this is a a separate
entity that we now need to reference
like we would do any other human and
that's hugely dangerous I mean we
shouldn't be teaching children that at
all
um and also there's a huge amount of
ambiguity around that idea so for
example let's say you are a student with
dyslexia and a blank sheet of paper in
front of you is is just your idea of an
absolute nightmare getting those Initial
Ideas down on paper is hugely
challenging now why shouldn't they be
able to use chat GPT or any other
mechanism using AI to structure their
ideas and to produce a work that's of
the best quality that they can produce
there's nothing in the guidance that in
the jcq around helping students with
these kind of problems to use AI to
their advantage they almost treat it
like it's the enemy which again I think
is really worrying
um and it reminds me of you know early
days of the internet where we were sort
of saying we need to keep children away
from
um away from this because you know they
won't be able to have any ideas of their
own they'll end up just reading
something online and sort of
paraphrasing it in their their essays
but now you know it's a really important
part of children's education is for them
to be able to critically read a body
information a body of information from a
variety of sources and pull out the bits
that they need you know why can't we
talk about AI in the same regard I saw
you the other day you know speaking on
the podcast saying perfectly capable of
reading something from GPT and not
taking it at face value why why do we
assume that children won't be able to do
the same and there's this worry that
they'll be sort of just cut and pasting
large amounts of information
out of these tools without really
understanding it but if if we teach it
children you know this is a new tool
that's available it's incredible but
you've got to use it in the right way
otherwise you know you're not you're not
educating yourself to the best of your
ability I think children are perfectly
capable of understanding that message
um we just need to trust them and give
them the the right skills to to use that
I mean to push back on that a tiny bit
and and I know this is basically
paternalism and Luciano fluidi said the
same thing he said people are lazy and
people take shortcuts they take the path
of least resistance and unfortunately
they can go to GPT and they can create
something which does what they're
supposed to do and I don't think they do
have the mental faculties to see that
the information is wrong and incomplete
because frankly a lot of experts can't
the real problem with GPT is is that
it's so plausible that the mistakes are
not easy to see now the first thing you
said really resonated with me which is
that it's it's actually us the the
people who are let's say you know early
40s late 30 you know onwards because
there's two types of cognition there's
generation and discrimination and you
learn those faculties together at school
and part of the reason why GPT is such a
great superpower to us is that we can
still discriminate so we exactly
generate we discriminate now another
factor to bring in is that part of the
reason why GPT isn't a risk at the
moment is because it's not very good yet
and it is very good but it has some
serious problems and when you use it you
kind of like develop a field for where
it's good and where it's not good but
it's um quite bad if you ask it
open-ended questions about its internal
knowledge base on things it wasn't
trained on ask it about Noam Chomsky it
will give you an amazing response
because it's densely trained on stuff
about Noam Chomsky it's really really
good at things inside the context window
from high resolution so basically
anything that you give it inside the
context window you summarize it ask
about it generate code it almost never
makes mistakes right but um but it does
still make mistakes if you ask it to
generate a script it has this kind of
character to it which is very monolithic
it doesn't seem very human it's very
constant in style so if you want to
produce a good script with it you have
to kind of adopt this hierarchical
recursive process yes segment it into
bits and you kind of change the style on
things and you change things and you're
actually doing this kind of like
reflexive process over many steps and
that's something that requires a lot of
intuition and a lot of knowledge but the
interesting thing though is in the
future that won't be necessary because
it will become so good that in a single
step it will produce something which is
just done and it's almost like the more
you engage with the meta process the
more you understand it the more engaged
you are with it and all of these risks
that we're talking about are attenuated
but what when it becomes so good that
you don't even bother engaging anymore
you just say oh it's done yeah well I
think like you said I think you know it
will I think our senses will become
fine-tuned to when something is being
produced by a GPT style model and when
it's not and I think I think the
recursive process is really important to
show students how to use these
Technologies because I don't think what
anyone's suggesting is that you know the
concept of an essay should be just
something that is
um you know you put the question into
GPT and you get the answer back I think
you know it speaks I think to what
examination is if it is possible to do
that I mean if if what we're basically
saying and I remember you know it's from
from our school days that I remember I I
had a way of writing essays that I knew
was going to get me a good Mark because
I knew the structure you know I knew
what that example we're looking for and
so in a way we were we were doing what
you know a GPT model does we just we
just churned the same stuff that we know
is following the right structure we have
to put the first bit is going to put our
point of view then we say that the the
counter arguments and then we summarize
and it is somewhat formulaic the process
of writing an essay so I think what GPT
is trying is taking away is some of the
mechanics of of of that process but the
ideas themselves
you know there is a I think there is a
lot to be said for students that can
then Elevate that
GPT output to something that really
reflects them and is their
uh their their way of describing a
particular or their their
um their unique style of writing and I
think you're right the GPT is is
somewhat uh it gives you a certain GPT
style answer
and I know you obviously you can prompt
to to kind of encourage it to be a
starting different style but I think a
good student would still be able to do a
better job of it at the moment than a
gbt model would do but you know I like
the idea that students are able to to
use this technology in a way that is
that elevates their own thinking and I I
you know I really hope that we find ways
to to embed this technology into the
curriculum in a way that doesn't make
students see it as the enemy first of
all but also doesn't make students rely
on it as a crutch there's a narrow path
I think that we can take that that
really tries to tries to find the middle
ground between these two ideals and I
don't think we're Beyond being able to
do this but it has to be really
carefully managed otherwise we're going
to end up
we stray too far one side or the other
and we end up just teaching students the
wrong thing about education about what
it means to learn
um so yeah I I think I think we need to
encourage students like you say to think
critically and that that means using all
of the tools at their disposal
critically and not just seeing well the
internet is something I should use
critically but gpt4 is de facto correct
and I should never question anything
that comes out of it
um yeah yeah I mean what you said really
resonated with me about the schematic
nature of let's say essay writing we all
know that it's basically a form of
overfitting
um all of the people in my computer
science course that did really well on
the exams didn't know computer science
very well exactly because you go through
all of the past papers and there's
certain patterns and schematics and
unfortunately what language models have
told us about ourselves is that we are
very schematic and it all comes down to
this mimicry thing there's always a
chorus of people who say well that's not
really thinking that's just mimicry and
even with creativity it's exactly the
same thing you know there's there's a
schematic element and there's also a
completely random element and not much
space in between so you know if you're
looking for this beautiful space of
human cognition that's neither schematic
nor completely random you'll be
searching for a very long time and and
the way people use generative models I
mean maybe we can talk about art as well
is that it's a very random process so
you might be sitting in a coffee shop
and you you see someone walk across the
street and you say oh I'm just going to
put that into my prompt and you just go
on this random Journey so that's quite
random or you might just say well I'm
going to look at what other people are
doing and I'm going to steal their
prompts and you just get this kind of
um combination don't you um yeah exactly
um you know I like I I like the idea
that uh we stop marking students on
their ability to to conform to a certain
structure that we're expecting in the
essay but the idea itself should be what
we're marking we need to Mark the we
need to Mark the student and not the
essay if that makes sense the essay I
think what chat you know any sort of GPT
model has shown us is that the essay
structure is something that is no longer
um fair game for for marking and that
by saying like you said a student who
writes a good essay about computer
science or a student that writes a good
structured essay about history that sort
of just doesn't stray too far from the
um the mark scheme
you know how good a historian or a
computer scientist are they
would it not be
more impressive to sit to receive an
essay that is full of interesting ideas
full of character full of individuality
but perhaps doesn't hit all of the uh
the structured bullet points in this
Mark scheme and you know I I like the
idea that uh these tools are allowing us
to be a bit Freer with our ex our
expression and our
um that we're not maybe as constrained
about how every single sentence should
sound and I believe me I've sat in front
of proposals and I've sat in front of
things that I have to write where I know
exactly what I want to say and I think
it's what I want to say is very valid
and is important but I just can't
structure the sentence I'm just you know
going it through in my head trying to
work out do I put this first or do I put
this first what hopefully these tools
are allowing us to do is to to move away
from the nuts and bolts of writing
because it's an incredibly mechanical
and
um nuanced process that actually it's
only through years of sort of doing it
that we understand what a good sentence
structure looks like well you know can
we sidestep that somehow and really just
focus on the idea itself and so I'm
spending more time instead of thinking
about how to write a sentence about the
idea can I think about three other
things related to the idea itself that I
want to mention and that's that's the
key how do we do that well you yeah you
just you just nailed it so I mean first
of all going back to the um the
benchmarks which is basically what exam
marking is in order to make it scale we
standardize the marking scheme and that
truncates creativity it creates
overfitting exactly and what you just
said is really interesting because
actually what we should be optimizing
for is the meta algorithm so the
creative process is about I've got in my
mind this meta approach of like you know
generating discriminating bringing
things in and maybe the next generation
of Education will be using language
models to Mark as well as create
um because then the marking process
would be something far more abstract
it's like well what's the meta algorithm
that they've used to create this content
but then cynically you might have seen
this meme that um you know you you use a
language model to generate an email and
then the person who receives the email
like you know turns it into bullet
points and it it's almost like you've
now got this intermediate space which is
completely useless yeah could that
happen to education yeah well that's
right I mean language has always been
the mechanism through which we're trying
to convey ideas and I suppose yeah once
you've got two GPT models talking to
each other then can we not just get to
the heart of the problem which is cut
the email chain out and just get to the
point at which we want to get to
um so yeah I think yeah it goes back to
the very point that we very started with
which is you know language is incredibly
flexible and it gives a actually an
incredibly accurate impression of
reality
um but the within an educational setting
we we used to obsess about things like
spelling and that you know I guess
spelling of your essay would be a major
part of which it was marked and now
that's less of an issue because now
everyone's spelling is going to be going
through a spell check
um on on Ms word or such like and I
think you know maybe maybe we're going
to see the same Evolution with the
structure of entire sentences and
paragraphs and we're not now marking as
much the
the uh the mechanics of idea conveyance
but we're marking instead the idea
itself and I uh it's so important I
think to to get to the point of uh you
know I would love anyone going through a
history class to be marked purely on a a
an obscure relationship that they've
found between two texts that they've
read maybe one in a different class
altogether and the history class that
they're currently taking or that they've
done some outside reading or and pulling
in ideas from an entire book and we
would know that they did that rather
than doing that through GPT because in
their Viva they would be asked in depth
about the subject and that they could
elaborate on it and they get excited by
it and they convey that through through
speech and um you know instead of now
you know here's your essay and uh yeah
this paragraph should have been a bit
higher because it doesn't really convey
the idea early enough and you know that
that sort of thing I feel is is a bit
mundane to be honest to be marking and
I'd love to see the ideas themselves
being questioned and challenged and that
will Elevate us I think as a
as a species because now we have a you
know hopefully generations of people who
can who can focus on what's exciting
about the subject and you know when we
take history we don't do it to learn how
to structure an essay better we learn it
because we want to understand its
implications for for the modern world
and also for the sheer Joy of learning
about these people in the past and
thinking about how they must have but
how they must have lived and how they
must have thought
um and I yeah I just I just think
there's a huge opportunity to really
use this technology to Focus Education
on the subject and less on the the exam
and the marking of that exam and the SAE
structure I mean we talked a lot about
essay writing and and uh I guess written
subjects like history geography and the
humanities but I suppose it also applies
to
um mathematics and and the Sciences as
well where we we can really we can use
the technology to to enable students to
to fight through roadblocks that they're
having with understanding
um a really interesting angle for these
large language models I think is to act
as personal tutors
um and I I've seen I've seen in the past
even with my friends and their children
how their students are using them for
things like modern languages and
um in modern foreign languages and and
subjects where there's there's there's
roadblocks in understanding that they
they can't express necessarily easily to
their teacher or they feel embarrassed
to do so or they haven't got the time to
do so or the teacher doesn't have time
to do so but there is now a mechanism
through which they can interactively
explore a particular idea without having
to resort to
frankly sometimes uh you know
embarrassing conversation with another
human about how they don't understand
something so the facelessness of a GPT
model might actually in some ways be a
benefit and that there's no there's an
objectivity about it that is incredibly
appealing for things like tutoring
um so yeah I think that's an interesting
angle as well yeah I completely agree
with that um I mean even as a podcaster
myself I've thought a lot about what our
value is and our value is in Bridge
Building because loads of professors do
Talks on YouTube not many people watch
them because they understand well
sometimes professors are amazing but no
like podcasting is is about helping
people you know giving them tools to
understand stuff and if you think about
the Bridge Building
where do you build the bridge from and
where do you build the bridge to and
I've thought about creating a portal
that people can log into to kind of like
ask GPT for questions and receive you
know retrieve information from previous
mlst episodes and and it can be
personalized because they can say I'm a
computer science undergrad and I know
about these things but you know like it
will kind of know which Concepts need to
be introduced because we use a lot of um
technical language and the technical
language is wonderful if you understand
what the language is because we've got
we've all got a world model and as we
were saying previously about the
Penguins we all understand the world
completely different so I assume that
this is the best way to communicate it
might not be based on the information
they have available to them so I really
agree with that another thing I wanted
to talk about is um in a way it's kind
of depressing that like you can go on
teams now there's this thing called
co-pilot where you if you missed a
meeting you can say can you summarize
the meeting for me and um you know what
team meetings are like the information
content is pretty close to zero yeah and
um that's actually quite depressing
because there's a sub game it's not
about what was said in the meeting it's
about the experience of being in the
meeting there's a whole kind of social
Dynamic similarly with education there's
a whole social Dynamic You're Building
relationships with people it's part of
the human condition and language models
might risk truncating that experience
and not only that information and how
you understand it there's a very
subjective component to it which will be
truncated what do you think about that
yeah I think what we'll start seeing
with genitive AI
um is hyper personalization in so many
aspects
um so I I'll come back to the point that
you made there around sort of Team
meetings um in a minute I think one of
the things maybe to say first is
certainly in the creative arts
what I think we'll start to see is that
you won't just have
um a track that everybody will
understand and hear and and we'll go to
the you know the top of the charts or
whatever the equivalent is these days
but what we'll start to see is that you
will be able to subscribe or
um to to buy into a certain uh style or
a certain maybe singers uh model of how
they how they approach uh creative
um production and that you will be able
to listen to
literally a different type of song from
that singer or a different uh piece of
art from that artist or or or uh Novella
from from that that writer whenever the
whenever you want and that you'll be
able to save that if that's one that you
particularly like that becomes part of
your library
and that you that's the hyper
personalization you will be able to
create your own music on the Fly I think
that will happen I really do
um you know we've talked about this for
years I think I mean personalized music
and I think the quality hasn't quite
been there and it's interesting to think
that that music is the last well one of
the last pillars through which we're
we're working on genitive AI text is one
of the first four Images obviously video
is now starting to get there but it's
obviously more challenging why is music
so much more complicated I find that
really interesting but then you know to
take it back to your point about team
meetings and and personalization there I
think yeah for sure that everybody will
have their own perhaps their own model
of what in a meeting is important to
them and that the CEO's large language
model of a meeting may be very different
and they will be able to pass it through
their own prompt of what they find
important than somebody who's actually
doing the work maybe a programmer
um and so the same meeting may actually
have different summarizations for
different people
um and yes whether you're there in
person or not I think what will be
interesting is seeing what as a as an
individual you carry around with you in
terms of a generative baggage and that
you might have a model that you you have
using within a work environment to
capture what's interesting to you there
and then you might have your your music
model that's um yeah everything that
you're listening to gets passed through
and it will be able to generate uh from
from noise I guess noise vectors what
you want to listen to at that moment in
time so I think hyper personalization is
just around the corner in the work Arena
but also socially and creatively as well
yeah I completely agree
um you said something interesting about
first of all music being significantly
harder than the other modalities and and
we should just quickly double click on
that but also what what do you think
about this notion of again we we think
we're really creative and
like if we if we did suddenly have
generative music and I would love that
by the way I listened to SoundCloud and
I listen to very repetitive kind of like
um I don't even know the type it's
called like future garage and wave but
I'm sure you could generate it but you
know in my mind I feel that a human has
gone through this creative process and
they've created something which is not
on the manifold but it probably is on
the manifold isn't it that's the thing
so do you cynically think that there
there is no new type or Paradigm of
music that could be created are we
truncating the possibilities by by doing
this no I I'm I'm optimistic about the
future of all creative arts because like
you said I think there are things that
sit off the manifold and by that you
know what we mean is that the training
data only takes us so far today and that
I think ultimately we are still
interpolating it's just that a lot of
the interpolation looks like
extrapolation but I think you know if
you if you boil it down to what what
models can do they are very very Adept
at interpolation between different
points on this manifold and it you know
sometimes that appears like something
completely new but it's actually a blend
of you know thousands and thousands of
different genres that create something
that appears new however having said
that there are steps that are taken
within music for example that just seem
to create a new sound that is genuinely
interesting that you would you couldn't
really describe as a mixture of previous
um genres
I mean if you think about say if you had
a large music model that was trained on
music up until the you know the late 60s
could you create music that sounds like
80 synth you know it's like well maybe
not because the technology just wasn't
there and also it's a sound that doesn't
really come across in any previous music
from from you know the 60s backwards so
I think what we need to do is encourage
and again it will Elevate and help us to
to create not just I mean look at you
know music today is is by and large a
huge
machine and even without generative
models I feel like some of the
some of the creativity is somewhat been
sapped out of the the music industry
because it's become a
a mechanism for generating Revenue
rather than for Creative output and and
new ideas that are too risky a lot of
the time
um
and yes there are people who do still
create wonderful music through largely
interpolating the same ideas I mean look
at Ed Sheeran's been taken to court
hasn't he over using the same four
chords as pretty much every pop song but
it's his music's still wonderful and
thousands and millions of people listen
to it so we shouldn't treat
interpolation as a you know something
that should be sort of sneered at I
think it's I think it's important part
of music making it's just that now I
think artists have the ability and I
would like to see artists embrace the
idea that their sound can be used in a
myriad different ways not just their you
know their one or two uh top selling
charts you know singles yeah um yeah so
interesting I mean because one thought
on that is there might be
um an analog with language so um you
know Chomsky had this idea that there
should be a generative grammar and
unfortunately all grammars leak
um but certainly we were talking about
the cross-pollination between
programming languages and and our
language and uh that there is a formal
grammar for python not leaky at all and
and similarly there's a difference
between sounds which are nice to listen
to so we recognize certain things as
music and that is determined presumably
by
um physical architectural configurations
in our cochlear and our brain and our
processing system and so on so there
might be a kind of grammar for music
which these models are learning and then
it's just a kind of a case of of
creativity combinations and sounds so
you could argue in in some sense that
the domain is is quite restricted yeah I
think um you know especially with music
making I think one of the interesting
things about why this has been such a
it's actually one of the harder domains
to to solve
um goes back to the fact first of all
there's not as much training data so
text is obviously usually uh prolific
and we have a huge amount of it in which
to train
um than to learn from and large language
models do scale remarkably well with the
training data set
um but also you're right that there
seems to be something very very
particular about why some things sound
good and once why something's down so
don't sound good and we we really
resonate as humans to the idea of
um that there are there are long-term
dependencies within a piece of music
that we we enjoy
the recapitulation of an idea or we
enjoy the sometimes the repetition of an
idea and that repetition has to be sort
of precise and it has to be um
yeah and maybe with a small adjustment
to it that elevates it
um and certainly within I think within
pop music or modern modern music I think
what we're seeing is that a lot of the
time these ideas can be in some way
um you know forced and can be in some
way sort of
um embedded into the music without too
much sort of creative process
um and and maybe what generative
modeling will allow us to do is get back
to the old school idea of can we come up
with something that sounds a bit
different from to people's ears and that
it's because we can generate this stuff
now at scale that there's there's more
opportunity
to to get things wrong and suddenly
something will burst through that just
sounds fresh new different rather than
having to take the risk on that idea
because it's it's just it's so difficult
to come up with something like that and
take the risk on it so yeah I think I'm
still hugely optimistic that creators
will continue to create interesting and
a a novel and and
um really powerful ideas but also
supported by technologies that allow
them to do that a lot faster and allow
them to do that in a way that
um that they can still stamp their
impression onto the music
um the other point I think to make is
that people don't just like music for
the the objectivity of Music they like
it for the personal story as well and
that's something that no AI model is
going to be able to give you is the
personal struggle of the musician or the
personal
um you know the the the heroes Arc if
you like of this musician's story and so
where the human aspect comes in will be
more around storytelling and more around
the I mean you know the the idea that
albums progress from one to the next and
that there's there is some sort of
progression it's not just every piece of
music sits on its own but there is
something about the artist that's
embedded into that song
um and that's what people buy into and I
think we'll still need that yeah and I
mean this is getting into the philosophy
of AI art but
um
exactly as you said there's an intention
um you know what what did the artist
intend what was the artist experiencing
um you know the ontology in
philosophical terms there's there's all
of the kind of contextual information so
all of these things construct meaning
and there is an intuition that AI art
you know at at least attenuates all of
those contextual factors because it just
becomes an artifact
um but yeah in in a sense
um you were saying something very
interesting about
um the kind of the correctness of a
piece so with music it doesn't it
doesn't really
other than following something which
sounds musical there's not a clear
notion of correctness with AI art you
know Gary Marcus spoke about
compositionality and and the art which
is generated still needs to make sense
in our world model yeah and then you
move over to language and then you've
got this concept of factfulness and
knowledge which seems to be an even more
robust form of like it needs to be a
certain way and not another way and I
was going to ask you about factfulness
because that's one thing that language
models cannot do so they they cannot
verify facts and there are lots of
clutches for kind of doing that but so
so you could argue that it's not really
saving students any time if they
actually have to go and fact check
everything but I just wondered like
could you sort of like extend that out
into art and music that you know
does it does it need to be correct in
the same way well yeah I mean even music
has like you say there's rules and
there's form around what a Cadence
should sound like and
the music seems to convey something very
you know deep within our our psyche and
certain patterns and and chord
progressions and
um and rhythms and uh and timbre's they
they seem to have some direct parallel
with our reality so whether it's a you
know a high energy
um uplifting beat or whether it's
something that's reflective or we can
use these descriptive words within music
you know it seems to be able to capture
all of human
um
yeah or if human existence seems to
exist within in the musical sphere
and so I think what generative AI is is
doing is almost trying to find what the
parallels are of
um of these human conditions within just
the simple progression of notes in the
same way that it's doing with the
progression of tokens and and words
um but the data simply isn't there or
there isn't as much quantity so it's
much harder to train the models
certainly within the public domain and
uh yeah I think
I think long-range dependency is also a
much bigger problem with
um with music because you mentioned sort
of factfulness and I guess music doesn't
have the notion of a fact it's not
nothing's ever wrong in music but
there's certainly some things that would
sound incorrect or would sound not
um not in fitting with the the the the
four bars that we heard you know just
maybe 30 seconds ago and so I I think a
piece of music is in some ways it has to
be even more precise because if if we
feel that it's too
um
the music doesn't progress anywhere
there's no Journey Through the piece
then we are somewhat unsettled by it we
don't particularly sort of hear of it as
a as a con as a whole and as a concise
unit we sort of just hear of it as sort
of segments of four bars that each sound
a little bit different so it needs to
have that contextual long-range
dependency I think I mean that's
actually a really interesting
distinction between visual art and
auditory art because you know there's
always the question of what is the value
of Art and some people say that it's as
you said the subject of experience the
intention the ontology blah blah blah
um some people say it's about
representation so in visual art um a lot
of art is representing the world as we
experience it and music isn't really
representing the world it's representing
something else I'm not sure if that
makes a kind of categorical difference
in how we generate it yeah it's a
fascinating I mean music music is
probably the the domain I I mean I'm a
musician myself I play the cello and
I've always found very very interesting
the idea that there's people would sit
for hours and hours just listening to
just sound waves I mean you know you go
to the theater you can sort of
understand there's a direct connection
there between the reality and what
people are doing on stage and that you
come away all with the same exactly the
same understanding about what's happened
maybe subtle interpretation or
differences
or you go to an art gallery and you can
you can see what people are trying to
convey and maybe Modern Art less so but
at least there's a still everybody is
viewing the same
um the same body of work music is
entirely different because I think first
of all you know people's auditory
impressions of what's Happening will be
will be different but then also there is
no direct connection music doesn't
really exist in that form in nature and
we have animal sounds and
um nature produces its own music but a
lot of the time the music that we're
hearing you know we hear Beethoven we're
not hearing his interpretation of how a
bird sounds we're hearing his
his way of converting audio into fear or
into uh Jubilation or Triumph and so
you know I it's interesting that we can
still we can still all hear the same
passage of music and feel those emotions
no two no one would say or very unlikely
somebody would say this sounds jubilant
and then someone would say I'm this
sounds awful I can't believe how you
know in major minor Keys major keys to
all of us sound uplifting just because
we've raised the third of the chord and
minor chords sound dark and and scary
um and you know I'm not I'm not sure
actually why that is why is it that if
you change this one note by a semitone
that suddenly you moved from Jubilation
to fear
um and what I suppose generative AI
models are trying to do is map the yet
uncover the the unwritten rules of Music
um and what makes music I think so
fascinating is that language we can at
least describe the grammar we can say
well it's wrong to put this adjective
before this noun or whatever it might be
in a certain language but music there
are no rules but there are implicit
rules there's no explicit uh thing to
say this is why um you need to you know
you need to finish this with a chord a
five chord and then a root chord but we
just seem to have all the same
understanding that that is how a piece
of music should should end and there's a
finality at the end of that
um so yeah I think it will be really
fascinating to see how generative models
approach music because we can't say to
them
we can't we can't judge them on the same
way of being well this is perfectly
grammatically structured you know we've
seen
um you know gpt4 very rarely makes
grammatical mistakes if ever but what
does that look like in music we don't
have the rule book we can't say we don't
know what AI music is going to generate
basically we can only say what sounds
good and what doesn't sound good to our
ears and that will be different per
person
um so yeah I think there's a huge there
is a bit of a difference there between
language modeling and music modeling
yeah it's absolutely fascinating yeah
and um it reminded me a little bit of um
Nagel's essay on what's it like to be a
bat and he was talking about this
potential of an objective phenomenology
and I'm sorry for using buzzwords I
basically mean your kind of conscious
experience and you because you were kind
of alluding to there being an objective
mapping between certain rules or schemes
of music and how they make you feel and
it's probably a bit of both maybe there
is some deterministic objective mapping
and some of it is actually more random
than we would like to
um admit for example when we all go to a
music festival and um you know with
various levels of inebriation we um
we're convinced that we're having the
same experience and in many ways we are
because we're experiencing the same
music we're in the same space and time
you know when you send a recording to
your friends on on the phone they don't
get it yeah exactly yeah they don't get
it
um but um but by the same token when you
go on a roller coaster ride and uh you
kind of experience fear but you can or
when you do a presentation you can kind
of convince yourself no it's excitement
because it's the same feeling you know
the mapping is is subjective and and
that's the thing you're in this space of
of existence and Consciousness and
ontology and all these words and music
does seem to be far more in that very
kind of like subjective space compared
to the other modalities yeah and and
hugely reflects the culture in which
it's produced as well I mean I'm talking
purely about Western classical music
music and Western pop music but if you
trained a large language a large music
model on say the pentatonic scales of
Asian music or music which involves a
lot more
um there's less tonal and more
um more about the the Rhythm or the you
know drum the drum beats the sort of the
instinctive kind of Drive of the music
rather than intonation I think you would
you you do have end up capturing
something about the culture of the the
people who have created that that music
um so yeah I think as well we if we're
training music models I think it's
really important in the same way that we
don't want to introduce biases in large
language models by uh you know only
training on on Western data sets or only
training on English data sets I think
you'll see the same thing with music and
that what large larger music models will
have to do is find a way of representing
different uh genres of music all in the
same sort of latent space and it'd be
interesting wanted to see if there's a
the same latent space can capture the
beauty of a Rachmaninoff piano concerto
as Ed Sheeran's latest number one single
do you need different music models to do
that or are they actually part of the
same manifold
um because they're using the same chords
they're using the same progressions but
the the the the whole idea of those two
pieces those two things is completely
different one is something you can put
on very background music to listen to
for a short moment of enjoyment the
other one is something that is is
conveying so many so much more about
that composer's ideas and
yeah I I I just find it really
interesting to think how those two
things might might compete and I think
as well with language modeling you're
always dealing with sets of tokens about
words or or um parts of words with music
there are no such thing as tokens
because
you either well you either model music
as a sequence of notes where those notes
have duration they have pitch they have
uh uh yeah tomorrow
but all you order it is the waveform
itself and which case they can you know
an Ed Sheeran track could be modeled in
the same way as a symphony because
ultimately they're both in the same
medium of of uh of waveforms with
frequency and and uh and volume so far
amplitude so how do we how do we as uh
generative modeling practitioners model
music do we just keep it in waveform
space or do we resort to notes but then
as soon as we resort to notes we're
biasing towards Western music because a
lot of Dramas and music don't have that
sort of
um representation of Music on the page
they are passed down through word of
mouth or they're passed down through
um column response you know and and
improvisation
yeah so interesting to see how we
develop this yeah I know and um I guess
something has just struck me as you know
we were surprised that um we thought
truck drivers would have their jobs
automated first and it was actually the
information workers and maybe we can
talk a bit about democratization in
general because this technology is is
very democratizing but
um similarly critics of AI thought that
um it would be okay for epistemology or
for knowledge and actually it's it's not
very good at objective facts and we
always thought it wouldn't do ontology
or conscious experience or subjective
States and as we've just been alluding
to
yes it can to quite a large extent yeah
so um in many ways our intuitions have
been turned upside down let's just
quickly touch on this democratization
point though which is that um in in a
way uh you you could be someone who
doesn't speak English very well and you
can now write beautiful essays you can
do programming you can do a whole bunch
of stuff so
um do you think that that kind of
democratization is is a good thing
yeah I do in short I think it levels the
playing field wonderfully
um we've always had the I guess the
issue of some people
having access to the best tools and the
best quality
um education and I think what large
language models are have the potential
to do is give everybody at least a a
fighting chance if they have access to
these models of being able to
being able to get started and you know
not become necessarily expert but at
least not feel they're working with a
blank page you know I think large
language models just solve the blank
page problem for so many different areas
um
that you know you're no longer if you're
like creating a react app or I was the
other day building a website um for some
GPT demos that we're doing as a company
and I I just wanted something on page
that I could get started with and you
know within 30 minutes there was the
website
um with all of the functionality that I
wanted and then I took over from there
and we've now got you know that that
website live so I think yes I'm excited
at the potential for this technology to
accelerate
um what we're capable of and I think
it's because it unlocks potential in
people that not wouldn't necessarily
have have had that potential unlocked
through lack of opportunity and lack of
um access to
to a baseline level of of um
understanding or a baseline uh sort of
platform of of intelligence about a
certain subject that's not to say I
think that
that's all you need and that everybody
now is a react developer or everybody
now is a website builder or has the
ability to write an essay on or a book
about a particular subject uh to to
Great levels of detail but I just think
we've raised the floor of the of the
problem and I think that's really
exciting
um yeah although even on that at the
moment though so gpt4 is you're limited
by the context window and when something
goes wrong and it's remarkably good I
said I did a react app over the weekend
as well and um it to be honest now the
the failure mode is is often in
um The Clarity of my instruction so
there's a bit of an alignment problem so
it did the right thing it did exactly
what I told it to do the instruction was
wrong and um and you and sometimes the
failure mode is I haven't properly
copied the text back to the react app
I've inadvertently deleted a line
sometimes gpt4 says dot dot dot you know
um use the existing code yeah Implement
that you know and I've like not noticed
and I've pasted that in and it was
actually my fault
um but admittedly though there are there
are still a few failures and that means
I actually need to dig in and I have to
understand how references and callbacks
work in react which you know it can be
quite quite onerous and so on
um we're in the UK and um we've got
hyperinflation our economy is is really
really bad compared to the rest of the
EU and we don't have a manufacturing
base anymore for the last 30 years we've
moved into this realm of you know High
Finance and information workers
knowledge workers I guess you would call
it and um you could argue now that with
the Advent of this technology
um our core value as an economy has just
become diminished because it's so easy
to automate that work
yeah I I I would say
you know I still see this as a tool and
I do think we shouldn't necessarily sort
of fear this as something that is going
to replace or completely
um overrule you know human output
um you know I I do think yes there will
be some jobs that are now a lot more
um based around ideas and around the
sort of
um
conceptual uh Concepts I guess than the
the mechanics of writing or the
mechanics of summarization uh the legal
profession obviously is a good example
of this where a large part of the the
expertise is in knowing where to look
for information and knowing how to
summarize very complex documents and
sort of pull out relevant information
and you know if large language models
are going to be used in this space then
I think there's a potential there for
great disruption but having said that
you know I don't think that that it will
mean that there's a lot of people
walking around without a a job I just
think that
we've always found that that jobs move
and that that there are
these people will find other ways to to
offer their services that is beyond the
mundane and I think
that's that's where the great
application of this is is it helps
people to move away from repetitive and
um
formulaic work towards something that is
hopefully of a higher order level of
cognition
um
so yeah I don't I never like sort of the
idea that there's a a an uncontrollable
threat I I think the the idea always
tends to be disproven sooner or later
um and that we'll just find other ways
to engage ourselves
um and that's for the better
so um Ellie as a yankowski was on Lex
and been on a bunch of podcasts and um
I must admit I've shifted my position a
bit because I've shifted from thinking
that you know what they're talking about
is completely crazy to
um I think there's a lot of very
interesting stuff I mean they say don't
talk about intelligence talk about
capability and when you use gbt for like
this thing is very capable it's doing it
admittedly it's doing the right thing
for the wrong reasons of doing it in a
different way to weave than to how we do
it but it's doing stuff in some cases
better than our capability but the the
real thing that I strongly disagree on
is this notion of a recursive
self-improving super intelligence so
what do you think about that I agree I
think that's uh also comic book thinking
and sci-fi thinking and I think it's
very easy to fall into this trap of if
if it can start programming itself then
it becomes super intelligent
um and I don't I just don't see that as
being a a viable threat and I think it's
very it's something that I've heard I've
heard sort of
yeah quite sort of respectable people
sort of talk about and the idea that
suddenly we're gonna all wake up and
it's designed itself to
um to have nefarious uh taking nefarious
actions in the world and suddenly we're
all um it's the end of humanity but I
think I think what we need to realize is
that you know I go back to the point
that what we've built is something
that's very capable of predicting the
next word and I know that's not
something to be taken lightly but
ultimately
we need to understand that there's no
embodiment at the moment of these
Concepts and we
you know we don't have the idea of uh
these large language models being
something that is able to it operates
basically within this theoretical space
and not something that is operating
um in the physical world so I don't
really I don't really agree that there's
more harm than good that's going to come
of this technology I think we'll end up
seeing it being used much more for
positive and for for good purposes than
it than running the risk of an of a of a
self-replicating or self
um improving AI
um because I think it goes back to as
well this pop this concept of Will and
wanting a particular outcome and
whilst we might be able to give the
impression of this through
goal-oriented uh chaining of large
language models like Auto gbt ultimately
I still think there's something missing
and that we don't really have the
ability to give anything a proper will
to do what it needs to knit so I'm with
you on the idea that uh
self-recursiveness is not something we
need to worry about at the moment yeah I
mean there's a couple of things there um
I kind of agree with you the thing is
I've spent so long now you know reading
Chalmers thinking about all this stuff
and when I first started reading about
Consciousness in silico I thought it was
a completely crazy idea and I you know I
kind of naturally agree with them so but
the more you think about it the more you
kind of think well
maybe maybe you could have Consciousness
in in Silicon and then you know
intentionality a lot of people argue
that that's strongly related to
Consciousness and
um yeah so there's this question of
would it have agency would it want to
kill us all and then even if it could
self-replicate that's interesting as
well so we're not talking about an
intellectual Santa Claus machine where
it kind of like materializes itself into
the physical world it might just be
creating little computer viruses that
kind of replicate around the internet
and and those those things will kind of
make it more likely that the thing
doesn't get turned off or something like
that so you know there's a plausibility
scale so that's kind of like one step up
on the plausibility scale and then I
think the thing at the top of of the
unlikelihood scale is that there's
something about the autonomous recursive
nature in of itself that can improve and
you know its intelligence and that I
take issue with because look at Auto GPT
Connolly he even said oh you know I was
warning you guys about this yes you know
this is this is why I didn't talk about
recursivity because I knew I knew that
all of this was going to kick off
and I'm looking at it and thinking well
this just confirmed what I thought all
along like it's crap it doesn't do
anything but um yeah but what is it
about this recursive thing that you
think they're worried about right so I
suppose the main thing is I think people
are now worried about the fact that
large language models have the ability
to to code and to code pretty well and I
suppose they are then sort of making the
leap to okay well if we've got large
language models that can code and can
reason therefore it follows that they
will want to code themselves and there
is a huge leap there between
a large language model outputting some
code because it's been asked to Output
some code to then saying it's going to
find the ability and people say things
like oh it will leap onto the internet
it doesn't for me sort of it's a
non-secretor to say if it can code
therefore it's able to sort of just leap
onto the internet find its code base and
start putting pull requests in
I think we also need to remember that
we have the ability now to write code
that can do a lot of damage on the
internet without Ai and and like you say
viruses that can spread rapidly so we
need to not sort of uh Blend or blur the
lines between
what AI can do and what it's giving us
and the ability to write code that can
do a lot of damage because the two are
separate and you know we we have now
viruses that can self replicate and
mutate and adapt to different scenarios
without the need for llms
um all llms give us the ability to do is
is
apply the same model in a range of
scenarios and I suppose this is what
people are worried about is that if you
can deploy one model that can in one
instance write some code but also in the
other instance talk to a human on an
email to convince them to give them
their password then you don't need to
suddenly have different models to do
each of these different things and that
you can deploy One agent that has the
ability to do everything altogether
um so I think there is a there is a a
valid concern of people using the
technology
nefariously and I don't doubt that there
will be some significant news articles
and stories about how this technology is
being used you know for bad reasons
however
I don't I don't want to sort of fall
into the Trap of thinking well is the
technology itself that therefore needs
to be destroyed and therefore needs to
be not progressed but we need to find
ways to stop Bad actors doing bad things
which has always been the case to be
honest
um
you know
for example
um cybercrime is an area where I think
large language modeling will really
start to uh have large impacts
and I think you know even
then you know the same it will be the
same challenges that we face with cyber
crime so detection and uh defense and
being able to quickly adapt to new
scenarios that haven't been seen before
um and it will just be about
understanding how this technology May
accelerate these ideas but it won't be a
different kind of attack or a different
kind of
um
entity that we're dealing with we've
just we just need to understand that
there are now ways to generate large
amounts of text very very quickly or
large amounts of code very very quickly
but I don't see it as being something
that will ultimately recurse back to it
wanting to update its own code base to
achieve a particular means but I totally
understand your this is something that
is very I can see why people think very
deeply about this and that there is not
a I'm not willing to say that I'm 100
certain that I'm right basically that's
the thing there's always a bit of a
lingering down yeah exactly why this
narrative has become so pervasive
because they always say well do you
really know yeah and then they say well
you know yeah it's it's a low likelihood
High magnitude event therefore we have
to take it seriously
um you know Pascal's wager and all that
stuff so um
yeah and I can imagine a situation even
with gbt4 that if you actually give it
shell access to an Internet connected
machine it could probably create some
kind of self-replicating code and they
will I'm sure be some big scandal in the
next six 12 months that there'll be a
virus circulating on the internet which
was created by dbt4 for sure all of that
stuff you know definitely could happen
and and then um the intentionality thing
just look at Bing GPT like whether
whether or not it's mimicry it does
appear to have intentions and thoughts
and you know I could see it potentially
doing certain things that could be
harmful so um yeah I don't know it's uh
yeah yeah I I exactly I mean I I suppose
part of me doesn't want to believe that
that would be possible and I suppose
that's maybe coloring my thoughts
somewhat but also I really don't think
I I don't I don't want to believe that
this is something that is
is going to be something we're seeing
um whether in the near future in the far
future I think we've we've got the
ability to contain control of the
technology ultimately I do believe that
I don't think we're going to see runaway
AGI
whether we see an incredibly powerful
General intelligences I'm more I'm more
convinced that that is true but I don't
I suppose the differentiator there is
that whether it's a runaway and I think
that's the key is that I guess people
people on the the one far side of the
the the the opinion would say well you
know I don't think we'll end up having
control over it and that it will end up
being something we've lost the ability
to turn off that's the bit I probably
would say is is not in line with my
opinion I think it's I think we will
always maintain control and we have the
ability to do so
um but as I say like the technology is
moving so fast it's difficult to to
Really sort of say with any certainty
um
yeah I mean I I think part of the
problem is they they imagine this kind
of demon which is this super intelligent
agent that's going to take over the
world and I think the reality would be
much more mundane than that it will be
we already have lots of hackers writing
yeah self-replicating programs and so on
now the thing is like if you look at how
corporations solve this problem they
force everyone to install security
agents on their machines and it's
something that I I always hate doing but
it's not my machine so I don't
particularly care
um but if the government told me to
install a security agent on my personal
machine I would absolutely lose my
I would not let that happen and could
you see something like that actually
because you know the problem here is
that
other than doing that how could how
could they possibly regulate this
technology
yeah I think I I think that there's the
people's you know people's fear over
this like you say stems from the fact
that they believe that there's a a an
overruling sort of demon like you
described that kind of wants to end
humanity and desperately doesn't want to
see its creator
um you know as part of its future but I
I don't I don't see the leap between
having the technology that we do at the
moment or even slightly more advanced
version of it and want and seeing that
agent in the world and the point there
that you mention around you know
if we're being asked to install stuff
onto our computers I I think that is if
anything an entirely sort of I think we
might you know see that anyway
regardless of AI I think sort of
overreaching on of the state side is
something that you know we're all sort
of used to seeing and I think that if if
we're seeing AI proliferate through the
world that it might be something that
um that we as personal individuals want
to kind of protect ourselves against but
that I don't see a sort of big bang
event that leads to uh huge amounts of
Regulation happening on AI overnight
because of some sort of catastrophic
event I suppose this is where a lot of
the runaway AGI ideas end is that they
believe that there's going to be some
sort of catastrophic event that that
ends up being a significant moment that
we we look back on and we say wow I wish
we'd have regulated against this sooner
you know there's there's often a
parallelism they're drawn between
you know the Manhattan Project and what
we're seeing at the moment with
um with AI being developed but I suppose
I I don't I don't really see the
parallel there too much because I
I suppose the the discovery that we've
made is that that language modeling in
itself can give the impression of
intelligence and that almost like is the
the scientific discovery that we've made
um and the if we're going to start
drawing parallels to things like
um
you know nuclear weaponry then we we
start to pull in the human aspect of why
these Technologies are dangerous you
know just because we've we've discovered
splitting the atom that that is the
discovery that we've made now we need to
decide what we do with it
um
and
but I don't see it in the same way that
there's going to be this big event that
causes us to reevaluate
whether the tech the discovery that
we've made is is a danger or not I think
you're right that it'll be much more
mundane and that we'll end up seeing AI
proliferate but in a way that doesn't
really cause the
um cause us to go this is horrendous
what we've just created we need to do
something immediately okay well let me
um give you a thought experiment which I
think is quite interesting so to these
people in the rationalist community
intelligence is literally
um being able to predict the future and
and Connolly he is a huge fan of um
friston he was a co-interviewer on the
first interview we did with him so so in
a sense these people think the same as
you they think that when you predict
Beyond a certain Horizon that you get
these like runaway events yeah so let's
say we had an intelligent and by the way
the reason why I don't think it's
possible is because I know that if you
if you take these trajectories these
predict prediction trajectories you're
traversing an exponentially large space
that turns out that's what everyone said
about language and it turned out to be
wrong so what if they could actually
predict our actions you know let's say a
certain number of steps into the future
and being able to do so created these
kind of like
um transient capabilities that could
lead to Doom
um is that completely far-fetched I
suppose I'd go back to the earlier point
which is that we already have the
ability to write very very
very very complex programs without the
need for a large language model to do
bad things in the world and that we need
to remember that there is a there is a
line that needs to be sort of drawn
between
computer programming in itself and the
ability to create agents and entities
that enact
things out in the world that are
considered damaging and the ability to
create
um create code and create programs that
are uh that are prompted in a certain
way to to do a certain thing and I
suppose what what these people would say
is that there's going to be a blending
of those two things so that the suddenly
you are not fixed to a certain set of
code in order to deploy your agent but
you can deploy it very very Loosely with
a set of prompts or a set of
instructions to generally achieve a
certain goal but the your point there of
the fact that this space is
exponentially large and therefore it
will have to find its way
through a very sort of complicated
sequence sequence of events in order to
achieve its goal and the beauty of
programming without large language
models is that it is able to do so it
you know exactly what you've deployed
and it's solving this one particular
trajectory time and time again
and if we we are able to create models
that can
in some small way Traverse not just one
trajectory but also have the ability to
spread and to find their own way through
the path through the through the
exponential space whether that creates
whether that creates danger I still
I still don't think so because I think
it would be more efficient in many ways
to actually just code up a series of
agents to do the things you wanted to do
rather than deploy a large language
model to try to find it out for itself
um and I think if there were ways to do
that that we would have already seen and
you know we do see cyber attacks which
are complex and involve
um you know agents that in some cases
wait for years on infrastructure before
deploying and can can
can wait and monitor different different
parts of the network
for a certain event to happen or a
certain vulnerability to become apparent
so what what we need to what we need to
really understand is whether there is is
there benefits to deploying an agent
that and I'm thinking I'm thinking from
the
um from the bad guys perspective what's
the what's their incentive to deploy a
large language model based
um uh virus generation agent for example
rather than just do it now with exactly
a particular attack trajectory and
building a series of
um of attacks that are that are targeted
and do one thing very very well rather
than a large language model that does a
lot of things you know 80 well
I'm not sure that there's a benefit at
the moment to you to doing that but I'm
you know I've always been optimistic
about these things I don't think that we
should be
we should be cautious but not terrified
at the potential and that there's
there's things that we can start to
conversations that we should be having
basically around this but there needs to
be it needs to be grounded in reality in
it grounded in you know not not not
hyperbole but real specific use cases of
I can write this today to do this how
are you going to defend against that and
I haven't heard I haven't really like
you say the auto GPT stuff is impressive
at face value but as soon as you dig
under the surface you realize this
actually gets itself in knots and it's
not to say you know it's not going to do
this in future and that we need to be
cautious but I think everything should
be grounded in scenario based reality of
what's possible and that we shouldn't
we shouldn't leap 20 steps into the
future and say well what about this
happening when we're still here we need
to understand what's in the immediate
vicinity an issue make sure we have the
right people talking about these things
and are aware of the potential
consequences and take actions
take actions based on what we can see
happening today rather than the Sci-Fi
version of the future
um yeah
David
absolute pleasure thank you very much
for joining us today oh it's been really
fascinating thanks very much for having
me on really enjoyed it my pleasure my
pleasure